Wir werden sie abonnieren, das heißt ich kündige euch schon alle an. Dann kommt das Intro, dann legen wir los. Ich spüre komplette Begeisterung und das ist die richtige Stimmung. Also dann legen wir los. Die Ligatour ist zurück, wir blicken auf La Liga, die Ligue 1, die Premier League und auch die Serie A mit den Gästen Alexey Mnuch, Christian Bernhard, Alex Troika und in einer eigenen Aufnahme Jogi Hebel.
Heute im Rasenfunk.
Na, ihr drei, die ihr bei mir seid, wie war die Winterpause? Wie ist denn das so, Alex, wenn man eine Liga covert, die eben nicht so richtig eine Winterpause hat?
Tja, erstmal hallo, servus in die Runde, muy buenas. Ja, zehn Tage Winterpause gab es diesmal allerdings durchaus. Also kurz vor Weihnachten. Eigentlich Luxus, ja kurz vor Weihnachten bis zum, ich glaube, Neujahrstag oder 2. Januar oder so. Pausierte Spanien. Mit einer Ausnahme, im Nachholspiel war ein Tag vor Heiligabend. Aber ja, eigentlich eine Winterpause, also zehn Tage Winterpause ist auch schon mal ganz angenehm. In Spanien gibt es halt einfach keinen Grund wirklich, eine Winterpause zu machen. Ist ja eh eigentlich was Altmodisches, so eine Winterpause. Ich meine, die Temperaturen geben es ja nicht her. Auch in Deutschland wird es ja eigentlich nicht im Dezember so richtig kalt, sondern eher so Januar, Februar, ne?
Ja, daran merkt man, dass du Männerfußball verfolgst. Bei den Frauen fallen ja immer noch die Spiele aus, wie die fliegen von der Decke. Also wir haben jetzt gerade erst wieder die DFB-Pokalspiele verschoben. Also wenn man die richtige Infrastruktur hat, dann geht es in Deutschland. Das kann man wohl sagen. Alexi, wie war bei dir der Winter?
Wir hatten nur knapp zwei Wochen Pause nur, weil wir hatten den fantastischen Supercup am 3. Und dass die Stars von Paris Saint-Germain nur sechs Tage Urlaub hatten. Aber wir haben ja keinen mehr Marke, keinen Cavani mehr. Wir haben sich ja immer einen Urlaub geleistet.
Hey, das ist ja schön zu wissen. Über Supercup und so weiter, da werden wir heute auch noch sprechen. Da habe ich Alex noch davon kommen lassen. Christian, ich weiß gerade gar nicht, wie schnell es wieder losging bei der Serie A.
Welche Winterpause? Ja, in Italien dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal wirklich gar keine. Am 23. Dezember wurde noch gespielt und am 30.
auch.
Also ganz normal der Wochenrhythmus. Ja, diese Serie A hat sich entschieden, dieses Jahr weniger Spieltage unter der Woche zu legen. Also weniger englische Wochen. Und dementsprechend haben sie jetzt den Winter mehr oder weniger durchgespielt. Oder spielen den Winter durch.
Und ist das für dich jetzt gut, weil du dann Aufträge hast oder nervt das?
Also ich finde es eigentlich spannend, dass es vom Rhythmus her weitergeht. Ich fand es immer so ein bisschen künstlich, so eine kurze Pause. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob dem Spieler – ja klar, ein paar Tage weg ist immer gut für den Kopf. Aber ich finde es eigentlich schöner, wenn der Rhythmus beibehalten wird.
Okay, also ich muss sagen, ich war sehr glücklich damit, dass die Bundesliga Pause gemacht hat.
Du bist auch Bundesliga-müde, Max.
Ja, na ja, ich weiß nicht, ob jetzt Bundesliga-müde ist. Oder schaut ihr halt mal alle Spiele von Wolfsburg. Ich glaube, das ist eine normale Reaktion. Ich glaube, das ist der normale Zustand eines Bundesliga-Zuschauers. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich müde ist. Und ich habe dementsprechend auch nichts verfolgt, auch von den internationalen Ligen, also was natürlich so an einem vorbei fliegt. Aber es war jetzt nicht so, dass ich irgendwie den Premier League Deep Dive gemacht habe. Das nehme ich mir zwar immer vor, vor der Winterpause, merke dann, aber ich habe gerade gar keinen Bock auf Fußball. Ich habe gerade ehrlich gesagt nur Bock, mit den Kindern Fußball zu spielen. Und das habe ich dann auch gemacht. Also, wir wollen sprechen über eure Ligen. Jogi Hebel kommt dann noch in einem eigenen Segment nach dieser Aufzeichnung. Und wir beginnen nicht nur aus terminlichen Gründen, sondern auch, weil wir schon länger über die Liga nicht mehr gesprochen haben, genau in jener Liga. Und da wollen wir Alexi über PSG sprechen. Das sind zwar alle pünktlich aus der Winterpause zurückgekommen, aber bei einem Spieler wirkt es fast so, als hätte er die Winterpause verlängert. Oder ist das jetzt zu hart gegenüber Kolo Moini?
Kolo Moini, das ist nicht hart genug, würde ich sagen. Weil er seit über ein halbes Jahr in Paris ist und dann nicht angekommen. Alleinspieler wie in seiner Situation, beim spitzten Spiel in Lyon am letzten Sonntag ist der nicht mal eingewechselt worden.
Krass.
Das ist ein Fach für seine düsteren Aussichten. Und der Luis Enrique ist ein Problem für den Ex-Frankfurter. Er ist verpflichtet worden, bevor Luis Enrique das geschrieben hat. Und er ist einfach kein Spieler des Spaniens, vom System her. Schemba hat Luis Enrique sein magisches Trio gefunden, mit Papel, mit Dembele und mit Barcola vorne. Du hast immer noch einen Asensio in der Hinterhand, als falsche Neuen. Aber 95 Millionen Euro für Colomboanis könnte der größte Flop der PSG-Geschichte werden. Denn wenn sich seine Situation nicht verbessert bis zum Sommer, ist er womöglich bei Borussia Dortmund oder Benet.
Aber Barcola hat doch auch nur zwei Tore erzielt, also nur die Hälfte der Treffer von Mourinho, der ja viel gemacht hat.
Aber es ist noch kein Stürmer, hat auch deutlich mehr Vorlagen. Ist mal investiert im Spielungszentrum für einen Wüstenriechespieler, der wiederum Papels Neuen installiert hat. Und Papel hat jetzt, glaube ich, acht oder neun Spiele in Folge auf dieser Position gespielt, auch wenn er da, finde ich, dann potenziell nicht am besten ausschöpfen kann, sondern eher von der linken Seite. Aber Bacola ist noch sehr jung. Er wird auch der kleine Lahm als Spitznamen tituliert, weil er einfach noch sehr flink ist, aber auch sehr dünn. Da muss er noch an Muskeln zulegen, so ein paar Kilos zu erstellen im Bereich. Und dann ist er natürlich Weltklasse, aber er braucht noch Zeit, um zu reifen. Aber die 50 Millionen Euro, die PSG ihm investiert hat, haben sich im Sommer mehr gelohnt als bei Colomboini oder Saloramos, der auch nicht über die reservisten Rolle hinauskommt und auch 80 Millionen Euro von Betrieger gekostet hat.
Na gut, man hat es ja bei PSG, Kata sei Dank. Aber ich habe es richtig verstanden, Bakula wird der kleine Lahm genannt, also der Philipp Lahm. Aber der ist ja 1, 86.
Der Lahm, weil er so dünn ist.
Weil er so dünn ist, okay. Ich hatte Philipp Lahm vor allem als Kleiner in Erinnerung. Hoffentlich ist er bei Social Media ähnlich ausdrückstark wie Philipp Lahm. Dann kann man sich ja auf viele neue Geschichten vom PSG freuen. Du hast jetzt so gesagt, Colombo Ani wird dann bei Dortmund landen, irgendwo anders landen. Jetzt hat ja aber PSG eigentlich keinen Druck rein theoretisch. Klar, das ist natürlich ärgerlich, wenn so ein Top-Einkauf dann nicht gleich funktioniert. Aber wenn sich irgendjemand leisten kann, so jemanden auf die Bank zu setzen, dann ja PSG. Könnte man das nicht aussetzen? Und kann es nicht vielleicht auch sein, dass sich die Rolle noch verändert? Weil wenn du erzählst, dass Mbappé jetzt in der Mitte spielt, Mourinho hatte ja auch gar nicht so schlechte Spiele, wenn er vom Flügel gekommen ist. Ich finde, zum klassischen Mittelstürmer ist er ja eigentlich gar nicht.
Das ist auch richtig. Wir sind bei der Frankfurter Eintracht, da hat er sehr, sehr viele Freiräume gehabt, die er in der Liga einfach nicht hat. Und da will er wieder gerne in die Windstelle gespielt werden. Er will auch sich immer bewegen, er will viele Freiheiten haben, die er auch in Frankfurt hat. Aber in Paris nicht. Das Neueste bei PSG ist, dass Ustmann den Mäle gar nicht mehr so oft verletzt ist. Damit konnte niemand rechnen. Er ist in der VW-Klasse, wenn er will, und das will er bei PSG schon, seit er dort unterschrieben hat. Wenn Bakula so weitermacht, dann hast du einfach das Trio vorne. Und dann wird es wirklich düster für Club Moini. Er zu ehemlich mit Frankreich, aber ich weiß nicht, ob er seinen Bonus in den Momenten hat noch lange unter den Schanzen genießen darf, weil seine Situation im Club wirklich der Zweck ist. Momentan gibt es keine besseren Perspektiven, weil wie gesagt, da hat er durch sein System gefunden, seine Spieler, sein Stammpersonal, zumindest an der vordersten Spitze.
Ja, genau, das haben wir gar nicht gesagt. PSG rennt mal wieder allen davon. Erst eine Niederlage nach 18 Spielen, 44 geschossene Tore, 14 kassierte Tore, 43 Punkte, damit hat man 8 Punkte Vorsprung. Und nur um das kurz zu illustrieren, wir haben schon öfter über NHTSA gesprochen in der Vergangenheit, aber die liegen gerade auf Platz 2. PSG, 44 geschossene Tore, NHTSA, 19 geschossene Tore. Das sind so die kleinen Details, die es da manchmal gibt, die kleinen Unterschiede. Dann wollen wir doch, wenn wir mit Dembele quasi schon die Brücke gebaut haben zu Alex, und ich habe versucht, sein Gesicht zu lesen, aber er hat keinerlei Reaktion gezeigt, als es darum ging, dass Dembele jetzt endlich seinen Verein gefunden hat. Das ist ja, musst du nicht Sportjournalisten fragen, sondern Ärzte in Barcelona. Okay, vielleicht war ich ein bisschen drüber. Aber die Situation bei Barca, sie ist nicht so unkritisch gerade. Wir haben in der Liga einen Rückstand von 8 Punkten auf Girona. Das alte Manchester City Märchen, das die an der Tabellenspitze drohen, haben wir ja auch schon drüber gesprochen. 7 Punkte hinter Real schon. Und das werden ja vielleicht auch manche da draußen mitbekommen. Alex, vor allem hat man jetzt gegen Real eine richtig heftige Niederlage erlitten in einem besonderen Umfeld, nämlich in Saudi-Arabien. Toni Groß hat ganz besondere Grüße nochmal rausgeschickt. Wie ist die Lage bei Barca? Und unterscheidet sie sich von den Krisen, die wir jetzt schon manchmal besprochen haben hier, also sowohl in dieser Saison als auch in der letzten Saison. Hatten wir das ja schon mal, dass es so Durchhänger gab?
Durchhänger ja, aber man sollte nie vergessen, so ein Klassiker und vor allem eine Niederlage im Klassiker, erst recht, wenn sie höher ausfällt, multipliziert natürlich immer das Befinden zum Positiven wie zum Negativen. Also wenn du sich eh schon so durch die Saison schleppst und da mal unentschieden spielst und da mal auf Mallorca, nur einen Punkt holst, bist du eh unzufrieden und in der Tabelle läuft es nicht. Aber dann im Klassiker kannst du halt einfach ganz neuen Schwung für die Saison mitnehmen und für dein Selbstbewusstsein. Oder eben so richtig einen auf den Deckel kriegen. Und dann verschlimmert sich die Krise natürlich viel mehr, weil dieses Brennglas so stark ist, dieses Klassikobrennglas, wenn man so möchte. Also ein Klassikoverlieren ist einfach für alle Beteiligten immer so ein Multiplikator der guten Gefühle oder der schlechten. Und dementsprechend, wenn Barsa eh schon nicht so super drauf war und immer mal wieder Punkte ließ und unzufrieden war, die ist das und jetzt in Klassikow nicht nur verlieren, sondern auch 1-4 richtig auf den Level bekommen, dann verschlimmert das die Krise natürlich ungemein.
0-2 schon nach zehn Minuten. Vinicius Junior hat da die ersten drei Treffer erzielt und dann stand es da schon 3-0 zur Halbzeit. Ich habe von dem Spiel nichts gesehen, aus diversen Gründen. Ich musste mich natürlich noch mal mit Wolfsburg auseinandersetzen. War es denn aber auch so schlecht, wie das Ergebnis es sagt?
Na ja, der Anfang war katastrophal. Sie haben direkt nach zwei Minuten den ersten Umschalt gegen Tor kassiert, wo sie einfach im Pressing nicht gut sind. Hinten, ja, unglaublich viele Räume offen lassen und dann überlaufen werden und direkt ein paar Minuten später das zweite. Also der Start war katastrophal, die Abwehr war mal wieder richtig schlecht. Oder besser gesagt, nicht nur die Abwehr, sondern das Verhalten gegen den Ball. Denn das beginnt ja mit dem Pressing im Mittelfeld. Wenn das nicht gut ist, dann geht es los. Also von daher richtig, richtig schlecht. Nach vorne war es gar nicht so schlecht. Die Mentalität stimmte und die Intensität auch. Aber hinten war es mal wieder wie in der gesamten Saison einfach nicht gut genug. Man darf ja nicht vergessen, was Girona vorhin genannt ging. Die haben sie auch 2 zu 4 zu Hause verloren. Also vier Gegentore in Barcelona gegen Girona kassieren, ist ja auch eine Hausnummer. In Antwerpen ging es nicht mehr viel. In der Champions League haben sie ja auch drei Gegentore kassiert. Das sind jetzt nur Beispiele dafür, dass du nicht nur Spiele verlierst oder dich nicht nur mal unglücklich anstellst, sondern du kassierst auch viel zu viele Gegentore, weil die Abwehr oder generell die Mannschaft nicht gut gegen den Ball agiert. Das ist natürlich ein Hauptproblem, wenn du immer wieder Rückstände hinterher rennst, vor allem frühe Rückstände kassierst. Das war, glaube ich, auf Mallorca der Fall, in Granada, ich weiß gar nicht, wo noch, überall, dass du immer wieder Gegner das erste Tor schießt, weil du zu leicht Gegentore kassierst. Dann läufst du immer hinterher. Real hat natürlich die Klasse, jegliche Fehler, jegliche Schwäche auszunutzen und dann noch eins draufzusetzen. Von daher war das schon irgendwie bezeichnend für die Saison, dass sie auch nicht nur verlieren, sondern wirklich auch vier Gegentore kassieren.
Was muss deiner Meinung nach passieren, dass auch der Trainer Xavi um seinen Job bange muss? Also in der Liga habe ich schon gesagt, da hat man sieben Punkte Rückstand auf Real und acht Punkte auf Girona. In der Champions League wird man gegen Neapel spielen. Kann ehrlich gesagt auch alles passieren in sämtliche Richtungen. Die haben auch ihre eigenen Themen. Aber wie kritisch ist die Situation für ihn?
Ich würde schon sagen, ziemlich kritisch. Wir nehmen ihn am Donnerstag auf. Heute Abend ist ein Pokalspiel nur bei einem Drittligisten. Der einzige verbliebene Drittligist im Tableau. Aber man weiß ja, gerade bei Drittligisten auswärts, da kann schon mal was passieren. Sie haben in der Runde zuvor bei einem Viertligisten gespielt. Und auch da übrigens zwei Gegentore kassiert. Nur zwei zu drei gewonnen. Also gegen einen Viertligisten zwei Gegentreffer. Klar, da fehlt immer ein bisschen Motivation. Und wenn du führst, lässt du schleifen. Aber auch das ist einfach kein gutes Bild. Und jetzt beim Drittligisten ist die Stolpergefahr natürlich groß. Lass das mal schief gehen heute Abend. Dann sprechen wir vielleicht schon morgen ganz anders über Xavi. Oder nächste Woche. Sie haben am Wochenende ein ganz schweres Spiel in der Liga bei Betis, die zu Hause richtig, richtig stark sind. Also das sind zwei große Stolpersteine. Neapel natürlich auch ein ganz, ganz schweres Spiel in der Champions League. Also von daher ist er natürlich unter Druck. Die Mannschaft gibt kein gutes Bild ab. Nicht mit Ball, nicht gegen den Ball. Viele Themen, viele Probleme. Und von daher wackelt natürlich der Stuhl. Interessant ist aber, dass er viel mehr Kredit hat als die Vorgänger. Wir erinnern uns zum Beispiel an Ronald Koeman, der viel schneller unter Beschuss war, viel krasser, stärker in der Kritik war, auch in den Medien. Nicht nur von den Fans her, Social Media oder so, sondern wirklich auch, dass die Medien da viel kritischer waren. Und bei Xavi, ja, das ist halt die Vereinslegende, ist halt der Kumpel von Joan Laporte, der Heilsbringer, sollte der neue Pep sein. Und der ist irgendwie ein bisschen, ja, wird sanfter angepackt von den Medien, sondern ist jetzt mal, also die Berichterstattung ist nicht ganz so knallhart. Vielleicht hat er da ein bisschen Glück quasi, denn eigentlich sieht es nicht gut aus bis jetzt. Also er hat wenig Argumente, dass man sagt, es geht über die Saison hinaus oder vielleicht sogar über die nächsten Wochen hinaus.
Der berühmte Steigeruch, da hilft er dann doch. Und ich sage euch, was das für ein Treppenwitz wäre. Wir haben schon so getan, als ob es klar wäre, dass Ancelotti Brasilien-Trainer wird, Xavi Alonso dann Realtrainer wird. Und jetzt wird Xavi entlassen und dann kommt die Reallegende Xavi Alonso. Weil vom Fußball her würde es ja perfekt passen, so wie er mit Leverkusen spielen lässt. Leck mich am Arsch. Da gucke ich mir dann auch La Liga an. So ehrlich muss ich sein. Und dann wäre natürlich die Bayern-Meister, weil das wird alles verunsichern. Dann blicken wir mal kurz auf die Serie A. Da hat sich auch so einiges getan. Das ist ein bisschen schade. Wir können jetzt gar nicht alles abfrühstücken. Was passiert ist in den letzten Wochen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber es gibt ja genügend Podcast-Formate, wo unter anderem all diese Gäste hier zu hören sind. Also müsst ihr eben auch da reinhören. Es wurde jemand entlassen. The Fired One bei der Roma. Ich glaube, den Witz haben wahrscheinlich auch Hunderttausende gemacht, jetzt wo ich so drüber nachdenke. Warum musste José Mourinho bei Rom gehen?
Ja, es war ein Montag nach dem 1.3. in Mailand gegen Milan entlassen worden. Und das kam schon überraschend. Dann nahm er Mourinho und seine Strahlkraft, über die wissen wir Bescheid. Dementsprechend war es wirklich ein Montag, ein turbulenter Montag im italienischen Fußball, den es so lange nicht mehr gab. Warum wurde er entlassen? Fangen wir mal mit den Fakten an. Die Roma ist im Moment Tabelle 9. Da müssen wir nicht lange drüber reden, dass das nicht das ist, was sie sich vorstellt.
22 Punkte Rückstand auf Inter.
Nach ganz vorne müssen wir ja gar nicht reden. Der eine Punkt ist aber auch, sie liegen nur 5 Punkte hinter Platz 4. Es ist nicht so, dass sie völlig aus der Welt sind. Es geht eben um diesen Platz 4, um die Champions League-Quali. Aber es kommen ein paar Sachen dazu. Sie sind 9. Sie sind vergangene Woche, das was Alex gerade angesprochen hat, auch in Rom sehr stark. Sie sind im Pokal ausgeschieden, und zwar gegen Lazio im Derby. Sie haben in dieser Saison wirklich enorme Probleme, und das nicht zum ersten Mal in den Spitzenspielen. Sie haben in dieser Saison jetzt zweimal gegen Milan verloren, Sie haben gegen Juve verloren, gegen Inter verloren, gegen Bologna verloren, die auch vorhin in der Tabelle sind. Sie sind gegen Lazio im Pokal ausgeschieden, Sie haben die Fiorentinas, Sie haben Atalanta nicht geschlagen. Also richtig große Probleme in den Top-Duellen.
War da nicht früher Mourinho eigentlich immer so gut? Heimspiele und Topspiele?
Heimspiele ja, er ist weiterhin geblieben, in den Heimspielen waren sie stark. Aber das mit den Topspielen haben wir bei der Roma letztes Jahr auch schon gesehen. Also es kommt nicht völlig überraschend. Faktisch ist es einfach mit einer Mannschaft mit dem Potenzial zu wenig. Und trotzdem kommt es jetzt aber überraschend. Man muss das ja ein bisschen einordnen. Also die Eigentümer bei der Roma sind Amerikaner, sind die Fritkens. Und nochmal, es gab jetzt Platz 9, schlechte Serie, alles gut, es gab Gründe. Aber was man in Rom nie außer Acht lassen darf, Mourinho hatte extremen Kredit bei dem ganzen Roma-Anhang. Also die Roma als Verein, Roma als Stadt ist ein sehr spezieller Fußballort, Fußballpunkt, sehr emotional. Und was Mourinho jetzt in den zweieinhalb Jahren definitiv geschafft hat, er hat wirklich wieder die Roma-Charme hinter sich, nicht nur hinter sich, sondern hinter dem Verein gescharrt. Die Roma ist seit mehr als zwei Jahren jedes Heimspiel ausverkauft. Sie hatten jetzt eben diese zwei erfolgreichen Europapokalreisen, erst den Sieg in der Conference League vor zwei Jahren, letztes Jahr den Finaleinzug gegen Sevilla im Europa League Finale, wo sie wirklich auch Pech gehabt haben. Wenn sie das Elfmeterschießen gewinnen, dann wären sie auch in der Champions League. Und das darf man in Rom nie vergessen, denn die Roma hat fast 13 oder 14 Jahre lang kein Titel mehr gewonnen. Also da hat es da ein Umfeld, das einfach nach Titel gelext hat. Und mit Mourinho war jetzt dieser – unter Anführungszeichen – starke Mann da, hinter dem man sich wieder vereinen konnte und der einen wieder von Titeln träumen hat lassen. Und nicht nur träumen, sondern auch den einen realisiert hat. Und dementsprechend ist das eine extrem emotionale Gemengelage. Und mich hat es auch überrascht, dass sie ihn jetzt rausgeworfen haben. Also es kamen jetzt nämlich ein paar Spiele auf dem Papier, das sind ein bisschen einfacher. Womöglich in drei Spieltagen wärst du auf Platz 4 oder 5, was wirklich total möglich ist, weil es da sehr eng ist. Was haben wir jetzt? Hellas, Salernitana, Caliari. Also sie hatten jetzt auch schwierige Spiele. Sie hatten Milan, Lazio, Juve, Atalanta. Also das waren jetzt auch alles keine Selbstläufer. Aber da muss es wohl logischerweise auch ein bisschen hinter den Kulissen zu ein paar Auseinandersetzungen gekommen sein. Mourinho war zuletzt auf jede Pressekonferenz von Mourinho. Ich glaube, da erinnern wir uns, ist speziell. Aber er war jetzt zuletzt schon, sage ich mal, manchmal in Höchstform. Also da hat man schon verstanden, dass halt auch Impfereien sehr viel im Argen liegt, denn das darf man nicht vergessen. Thiago Pinto, der Sportdirektor, hört jetzt Ende der Transferperiode im Januar auf. Also Roma ist im Moment ohne Sportdirektor und ohne Mourinho. Also da gibt es schon riesen Vakums und dementsprechend eine Geschichte, die in Italien für Riesen, im Fußball Italien Riesenthema ist, weil Mourinho halt einfach immer noch eine große Figur ist. Und jetzt kommen wir zum Nachfolger, weil es führt ja auch da wunderbar rein, die Roma hat da nieder der Rossi geholt. Und der Rossi ist neben Totti die Roma-Legende schlechthin.
Wird es sogar about Stahlgeruch? Was heißt denn Stahlgeruch auf Italien? Ist das eigentlich überhaupt ein Begriff in Italien? Stahlgeruch ist ja eigentlich schon weird, dass wir das in Deutschland sagen.
Also so eins zu eins gibt es das gar nicht. Aber der Rossi und die Roma, also ich würde sogar sagen, dass der Rossi noch enger mit der Roma verbunden ist als Totti. Sein Vater hat ewig lang die Primavera trainiert. Er ist wirklich in Trigoria im Trainingszentrum aufgewachsen und war immer Kapitän Futuro, also doch zukünftiger Kapitän, weil er zusammen mit Totti gespielt hat. Und klar, als Totti da war, war Totti der Kapitän. Und das ist jetzt eine sehr romantische Entscheidung, der Rossi zu holen. Ich finde, die Fritkens spielen da auch ein bisschen mit den Gefühlen der Roma-Fans, weil klar war, wenn sie Mourinho rausschmeißen, dann ist erstmal ein Riesenalarm sozusagen im Umfeld. Und jetzt besänftigst du das halt erstmal, weil du quasi die nächste Legende installierst. Das ist das, was man dafür sprechen lassen kann. Er ist emotional und unfassbar mit dem Verein verbunden. Er war ein defensiver Mittelfeldspieler, also er hat sicherlich auch die Vision vom Spiel. Er war im Trainerteam von Mancini bei der M. Das sind die positiven Gründe. Aber jetzt kommen wir halt zu den vielen Fragezeichen. Er hatte eine Erfahrung als Chef-Trainer bisher und die ist vier Monate gelaufen, letztes Jahr in der Serie B, bei Spal, dann wurde er schon wieder entlassen. Also er hat keine Erfahrung auf dem Gebiet. Und dem jetzt das aufzuordnen, mitzugeben, finde ich aus Vereinssicht ein großes Risiko. Ich muss aber sagen, noch größeres Risiko aus seiner persönlichen Sicht. Genau, dass er das macht. Wenn das jetzt schiefgeht, dann hat er logischerweise noch einen riesigen Klotz für seine eigentlich angepeilte Trainer-Karriere. Aber ich traue es ihm zu. Ich glaube, er bringt vieles mit, was ein Trainer braucht. Spalletti hat dieser Tage auch über ihn gesprochen. Er hat gesagt, wir sind immer in Kontakt. Er hat lange unter Spalletti auch gespielt. Er hat gemeint, und das kann man der Rossi wirklich zugute halten. Der Rossi war immer ein Teamspieler. Der Rossi war nie einer, der für sich gespielt hat, sondern für die Mannschaft. Das wird er jetzt sicherlich auch versuchen, wieder sozusagen einzubringen. Aber es ist ein Wagnis. Es ist ein Wagnis für die Roma, es ist ein Wagnis für ihn. Mal schauen, was da rumkommt.
Also, Return of the Bundesliga-Vergleiche, das wäre, als ob Lukas Podolski jetzt Trainer bei Köln geworden wäre.
Ja, geht vielleicht. Also noch mal der Rossi und die Roma, also unfassbar enge Verbindung. Darüber müssen wir nicht diskutieren, aber der Rest muss ich zeigen.
Der Rest muss ich zeigen.
Dann könnt ihr auch mit Xavi und Barca vergleichen, weil es nahe liegt, so ein bisschen.
Das stimmt, ja. Aber Xavi hat ja vorher, wo hat er trainiert? Aber immerhin war er da ein bisschen länger Trainer. Aber ja, stimmt schon. Und Podolski spielt ja noch, der soll ja in anderer Funktion zum FC kommen. Aber wir haben gar keine Zeit, über Lukas Podolski zu sprechen. Und das ist eigentlich irre, weil wir sonst hier immer über Lukas Podolski sprechen in jeder Ausgabe. Alexi hat noch ein zweites Thema, und danach verabschieden wir ihn nämlich auch schon. Alexi, worüber müssen wir noch sprechen mit Blick auf die Liga?
Über den Tabellen dritten. Stadbrecht, könnt ihr mir bitte einen Spieler nennen?
Oh, das ist gemein. Ich habe den Tab noch nicht aufgemacht. Nee, warte.
Ich habe hier zu zeigen, dass das eine Sensation ist, was schon noch ein magerer Begriff für den Verlauf dieser Saison ist. Das ist ein Verein aus der Britannien, ein Traditionsverein. Aber mit einem der Känzendudges der Liga galt auch schon am Anfang der Saison als Abschließkonzert Nummer 1 oder 2. Und man steht nach 18 von 34 Spieltagen auf Platz 3. Das ist eine Mannschaft, die sehr unangenehm ist, sehr stark in der Defensive ist. Und mit einem Trainer, Jérig Roald, der eine große Spielerkarriere hatte, unter anderem bei Niksa und Olappik Marseille. Dann kommt die Frage, ob er in die Champions League kommt und sorgt dafür, dass von ersten Mal im Herbst die Allianz Arena nicht ausverkorbiert wird. Dann werden die Allianz Arena gegen Brest kommen. Aber Spaß beiseite, es ist schon zuzutrauen, dass Brest da oben mithält, weil das sagt man schon seit Wochen, die werden einbrechen und sie auch nach der Winterpause nicht, sind auch im Pokal noch dabei. Andere größere Mannschaften wie Marseille, Niksa, Monaco, die schwächen immer wieder. Und deswegen ist vielleicht eine historische Chance für Brest da, vielleicht nicht in die Champions League, aber zumindest im Europapokal, dabei zu sein in der kommenden Saison, weil auch die ersten sieben mit der neuen Champions League nach Europa können oder dürfen. Und es ist auch ein Verein, einer der wenigen Vereine, die seit Jahren auf Kontinuität setzen, auf Akribie mit einem Sportdirektor, der auch auf dem Transfermarkt immer sehr besonnen und sorgfältig umgeht. Und deswegen hat man ein Kollektiv geformt, der wirklich schwer zu schlagen ist. Und am nächsten Spieltag, was haben wir?
Das Match to Watch haben wir damit auch schon abgefrühstückt. Brest ist auch in der Winterpause an mir vorbeigeflogen, weil – natürlich jetzt wieder Bundesliga-Vergleich, sorry – aber es ging um diejenigen Teams, die sich im Vergleich zur Vorjahresplatzierung am besten verbessert haben. Und da war Stuttgart, glaube ich, auf eins. Und Brest müsste dann nämlich, glaube ich, schon die 2 gewesen sein. Also es ist quasi der VfB Stuttgart, der Ligue 1. Aber weil du uns jetzt nach den Spielern gefragt hast, welchen Spieler hätten wir denn kennen sollen? Also wer ragt denn da heraus?
Ich würde sagen, der Hauptgarant ist der Trainer. Aber in der Mannschaft an sich, Díales Melú, das ist ein Spielmacher, nicht so modern, also der alteren Art, aber der, den du gerne in der Mannschaft hast, weil der sehr clever ist, sehr intelligent, technisch sehr stark und jetzt vom Nachbar reden, begehrt wurde für den Winter. Aber die Tür ist geschlossen. Und auch Brassi, das ist der Abwehrchef, der wird von Stuttgart und Leverkusen heiß umworben. Ich glaube, da kriegst du ihn auf dem Arzt im Mailand.
Nicht nur von Stuttgart und Leverkusen, ja, genau. Da sind auch mehrere Italiener dran.
Genau, bis zum 31. Januar noch. Breis verlassen könnte. Er hat die Möglichkeit zu gehen, laut dem Präsidenten von Breis, und das wäre natürlich ein herber Rückschlag für die Bretonen, wenn der Abwehrchef in den Winter gehen sollte, aber es heiß umworben.
Das wäre jetzt meine Frage gewesen, Alexi. Kann es sein, dass sie ihn wirklich abgeben jetzt im Winter sogar? Milan und Napoli sind dann wirklich sehr, mehr als nur interessiert. Besteht da wirklich die Möglichkeit, dass sie ihn jetzt ziehen lassen?
Ja, das hat der Präsident oder der Sportdirektor, Gregor Lorenzi, gesagt. Der Einzige, der gehen kann jetzt im Winter, ist Brazil, weil man auch eine gewisse Ablöse kassieren könnte. Weil die wissen, dass der heiß und warm ist aus der Bundesliga, aus der Serie A und auch aus der Premier League. Und das könnte schon viel Geld in die Klasse bringen. Aber dann würden die sportlichen Ziele wohl gefährdet werden. Auch wenn natürlich das nicht die Champions League ist, sondern ein Klassenerhalt.
Das ist schon krass. Ja und wer weiß, wenn da jetzt schon so viele andere Vereine dran sind, man weiß nie, ob nicht drei Stunden vor dem fertigen Wechsel der FC Bayern dann auch sagt, ach Moment, da gibt es einen Innenverteidiger. Den kennen wir ja gar nicht. Den hatten wir schon ganz lange auf dem Titel. Wir schlafen schon die ganze Zeit in Lilian Brasset-Bettwäsche. Möchtest du nicht zu uns kommen? Das ist ihnen ja auch zuzutrauen. Soll schon vorgekommen sein. Alexi, wir entlassen dich, nachdem du uns noch die drei Awards verlieren hast. Einmal MVP der aktuellen Phase, vielleicht ein Anzang Hero, der immer so ein bisschen untergeht. Und gab es vielleicht auch einen Moment in der Ligue 1, den du besonders bemerkenswert fandest in den letzten Wochen?
Das MVP ist tatsächlich ein Deutscher. Es gibt nur noch drei gerade in der Ligue 1. Um ihn so zu loben bei Monaco, Vanuvin Kassmir in Toulouse und Reda Kadra bei Reims, der nie in der Bundesliga gespielt hat, nur der junge Borussia Dortmund spielt in der U21 manchmal mit. Und jetzt hat er sich in der Reims durchgesetzt. Reims ist auch die zweite Überraschung der Saison. Und zuletzt hat er ein Riesenspiel gemacht in Monaco. Am Samstag war das bei Adi Rühter. Er hat die Monaco-Gersten richtig gewehrt, mit einem Traumtor als technischer Backup. Er ist als Nummer 9 eingesetzt worden. Also Herr Nagelsmann, wenn Sie noch einen Goalgetter brauchen für die tolle EM im Sommer, schauen Sie in die Champagne und nicht immer in die Premier League. Ich würde gern ausnahmsweise mal Olympique Lyon loben, denn der ist ausnahmsweise mal auf dem Transfermarkt. Gestern hat er ein richtiges Coup gelungen mit der Verpflichtung von dem Nigerianer, der Bruder von Boniface, nämlich Gift Orban von Gent, für 13 Millionen Euro, der auch heiß und beworben wurde, von etlichen Bundesligisten. Und er geht an die Roren. Mal sehen, ob es sich lohnt, aber eigentlich mal hat Ligung zumindest auf dem Papier dafür einen großen Erfolg gesorgt.
Okay, und gab es noch einen Moment in den nächsten Wochen, den du bemerkenswert findest?
Ja, mir stört schon, was du vorhin zum Anfang der Sendung angedeutet hast. Midsa ist zweiter und hat nur 19 Tore erzielt. Das macht schon Angst, dass du das hinfühlst. Natürlich haben die eine tolle Abwehrmigrantin, der 40 ist und noch nächste Saison spielen will. Aber nach vorne geht ganz wenig. Und wenn die wirklich mit Champions League gehen sollten, das macht mir schon ein bisschen Angst. Aber die anderen sind auch nicht besser. Monaco keine große Konstanz, Marseille ist weg. Da liegt da keiner mehr durch. Und deswegen scheint das da, auch wenn Paris davon eilt ganz vorne, also in der Tabellenspitze, sind die auch nicht überragend in der Saison. Hat man in der Champions League gesehen, wo sie mit Kraft und Kraft weiter kamen in der Dortmund-Gruppe und auch noch lange nicht durch sind gegen St. Sebastian, da gibt es viele Baustellen in der französischen Ligue 1. An einer Zeit, wo die Rechte gerade neu vergeben werden, da gibt es schon viele Sorgenfalten bei den verantwortlichen.
Ja, nicht so besonders viele Tore. Also die Teams, die mehr als ein Tor pro Spiel erzielt haben, das sind gar nicht so viele, wie man meinen würde, bei einer Liga wie der Ligue 1. Und nachdem man ja seine Medienrechte für immer verkauft hat und nicht so wie alle anderen für einen begrenzten Zeitraum. Glückwunsch nochmal an den Vertrag des Monats an die Liga. Ist das wirklich ein Thema? Alexi, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst. Du musst weiter, kannst hier einfach auflegen und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich bald wieder. Macht's gut. Und wir blicken nochmal auf La Liga, würde ich sagen, bevor wir uns da nochmal der Serie A widmen. Da wollen wir sprechen über Athletik. Athletik, Bill Bauer, das dürfte unter anderem mit dem Rang 3 zu tun haben, den die gerade inne haben. Punktgleich mit Barca, Teil der Krise von Barca. Was macht den Athletik gut?
Was machen sie gut? Sie spielen richtig, richtig schönen Vollgasfußball. Ich glaube, da würde auch euch gefallen. Im Dauerlauf gehen sie auf den Gegner drauf gegen den Ball. Unfassbar laufstark. Man kennt das ja aus Bauern, diesen athletischen Fußballspielen.
Wie heißt der Athletik?
Wie bitte? Ach so, ja.
Der lag doch eindeutig da.
Auf jeden Fall spielen sie unfassbar mutigen Fußball. Laufstark gehen drauf, wie gesagt. Laufen ihre Gegner nieder. Und anders als in den letzten Jahren, schießen sie plötzlich auch Tore und Münzen diesen Spielstil in Tore um. Und vor allem in einem offensiv viel besseren Spiel als sonst. Sie hatten in den vergangenen Jahren immer große Probleme, Tore zu schießen. Man weiß ja, sie kaufen immer nur Basken oder holen immer nur Basken bzw. Spieler mit baskischen Hintergrund, baskischen Wurzeln. Der Spielerpool ist ja nicht so groß und da mal einen Knipser finden, schwierig. Und plötzlich schießen sie in diesem Jahr Tore. Also nicht nur, dass sie mehr Spiele gewinnen. Wer hätte es gedacht, wenn du mehr Tore schießt, steigt die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du mehr Punkte holst. Sie haben, glaube ich, die viertmeisten oder drittmeisten Tore in der Liga geschossen, wobei der Barca ein Spiel weniger hat. Aber sie schießen plötzlich wirklich viele Tore. 38 in 20 Spielen. Also das ist schon bemerkenswert, wie sehr sie da Vollgas geben und auch mit dem Ball dem Gegner richtig, richtig Probleme haben. Denn, dass sie unbequem zu bespielen sind, weiß man immer. Aber in aller Regel haben sie sich gegen kleinere Teams, wenn die hinten drin stehen, Abstiegskandidaten, einfach schwer getan, etwas mit Ball zu kreieren. Und das machen sie viel besser in der Saison. Und eben vorne viel, viel bissiger, viel, viel torgefährlicher. Ich glaube, die zweiteimstärkste Mannschaft La Liga sind sie. Sie haben beispielsweise Atletico Madrid zu Hause hochverdient geschlagen, wirklich überrannt, muss man echt sagen, im Wortsinne. Sie haben jetzt das Baskendorbi gegen Real Sociedad, den ganz großen Rivalen, 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Voller Selbstvertrauen, voller Selbstbewusstsein, Vollgasfußball und holen die Punkte unter Ernesto Valverde, dem Ex-Barca-Coacher. Bei Barca übrigens, und jetzt spanne ich so ein bisschen wieder die Brücke zu dem, was ich vorhin gesagt habe. Beim FC Barcelona wurde er entlassen, als er Erster in La Liga war und im Supercup im Halbfinale ausgeschieden war. Und jetzt zurück zu Xavi, der ist nur Dritter, Vierter in La Liga und kriegt eine Klassikoklatsche und ist aber noch im Amt. Auf jeden Fall, weil Werder hat jetzt wirklich im 2. Jahr den Athletikklub ausgebaut, wirklich verwandelt, wirklich weiterentwickelt um 2, 3 Schritte.
Und das ja auch mit einer ganz interessanten Katerstruktur, also dadurch, dass man ja eben den kleineren Pool hat, ist, glaube ich, Athletik schon eines der älteren Teams in La Liga. Und wenn ich mir vor allem angucke, ich dachte mir jetzt, da hüpft irgend so ein 20-Jähriger rum, der irgendwie die ganzen Tore gemacht hat.
Da hüpft schon in den beiden Williams-Brüdern, hüpfen schon jüngere Spieler rum, wobei Iñaki ist älter, aber Nico Williams ist Anfang 20, glaube ich. Ich meine, er spielt ja nicht sogar noch U21, oder zumindest war letztes Jahr, glaube ich, in der U21. Also das ist schon so eine junge Entdeckung, das muss man schon sagen, doch.
Ja, okay, aber ich habe mir eben die Top-Torschützen angeguckt und da haben wir eben Iñaki Williams, über den haben wir doch auch schon öfter in der Ligatur gesprochen. Also ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, dass wir den Minst schon dreimal erwähnt haben in den letzten drei Jahren. Der hat acht Tore gemacht und Guru Ceta hat auch acht gemacht. Stimmt aber natürlich, Nico mit 21 Jahren hat immerhin drei gemacht und fünf vorgelegt. Wahrscheinlich habe ich da einfach ein bisschen ungenau hingeguckt.
Er ist ja mehr Flügelspieler, der wirklich Dampf über außen macht und da eben mehr kreiert, als dass er selbst verwandelt, aber ist ja noch jung. Aber das zeigt ja schon auf, dass es zwei Spieler mit ein paar Toren gibt. Das gab es in den letzten Jahren nicht. Dass sich da die Last auch ein bisschen verteilt und dass sie ja verschiedene Waffen haben, unberechenbare sind. Das ist schon ja auch ein Beweis für die Stärke des Kaders auch oder für die Weiterentwicklung des Kaders.
Wie siehst du denn die aktuelle Situation so generell in La Liga? Weil wir haben im Grunde alle Teams schon irgendwann mal besprochen, die da oben drin stehen. Es gibt so einen klaren Cut zwischen den Top 5 und den Teams, die danach kommen. Also Top 5 aktuell, Athletico mit 38 Punkten gerade noch dran. Danach dann schon sechs Punkte Abstand. Aber eben mit Athletic und Girona 2 mit dabei, mit dem man nicht gerechnet hätte. Hat sich da irgendwas verändert? Liegt das daran, dass andere schwächeln?
Ja, da muss man schon sagen, dass sich was verändert hat. Denn genau das war in den letzten vielen Jahren nicht der Fall, dass du da wirklich Teams hattest, mit denen du nicht rechnen konntest, die da oben reingestoßen sind. Aber nicht nur am fünften Spieltag plötzlich da Erster, Zweiter waren, sondern wirklich jetzt nach der Hinrunde ganz da oben sind und auch völlig verdient da oben sind. Also in Girona und Athletic Bilbao hast du ja gleich zwei Beispiele dafür, dass da die Tabelle ein bisschen auf den Kopf gestellt wurde. Natürlich Sevilla, über die wir immer wieder gesprochen haben, die Kriesel natürlich im zweiten Jahr jetzt erst recht krass sind wieder unten im Abstiegskampf. Dass die so weit runter rutschen, abrutschen in zwei Jahren in Folge, konnte man auch nicht sehen. Klar, du hast mal ein schwächeres Jahr, aber dass du wirklich im Abstiegskampf steckst, ist ja beispiellos, ist ungewöhnlich. Und genauso ist es ehrlich gesagt sehr ungewöhnlich, dass in Girona da so ein Underdog ganz oben ist und im Athletic Club Bilbao jetzt eine Mannschaft ja in den Top 3, Top 4 nachhaltig offenbar in der Saison zumindest mitmischen kann und auch hochverdient mitmischen kann. Also dieser Rang da oben, der ist verdient. Ob es jetzt 3. oder 4. oder 5. sind, klar. Ein Sieg hin oder her. Aber grundsätzlich die Entwicklung ist so, dass sie da verdient in diesen Rängen stehen. Und das ist schon was Neues, denn normalerweise in der Liga war die Tabelle immer vorstgefahren. Barca und Real ganz oben, knapp dahinter. Athletic Club meistens 3. Und dann hast du eigentlich Sevilla 4. Und dahinter hattest du immer Betis, Reals, Serrat, Villareal, die so Platz 5, 6, 7 untereinander ausmachten. Und das war's. Das ist ungewöhnlich.
Das ist echt interessant. Und Multiclub Ownership. Vielleicht fühlt sie ja sogar mal zu richtigen Erfolgen. Im Beispiel von Girona. Das hat sich der FC Bayern auch gedacht und ist jetzt indirekt an Grasshopper Zürichs beteiligt. Habt ihr das mitbekommen? Die haben ja Red & Gold gegründet. Das ist quasi extra eine eigene Firma, nur für Multiclub Ownership. Dann haben sie sich aus Montevideo, glaube ich, einen uruguayanischen Traditionsclub gekauft, zusammen mit Los Angeles FC. Die sind quasi beide Teilhabe dieser Firma, was insofern schlau ist. Los Angeles FC hat jetzt die Grasshoppers sich gekrallt, 80 Prozent der Aktien gekauft. Grasshoppers ist ja eines der ältesten Nicht-Premier League-Aktien-Gesellschaftsunternehmen. Ich glaube schon 1981 sind die an die Börse gegangen. Habe ich damals noch im Kicker gelesen. Also nicht damals, da war ich minus vier, aber für elf Leben habe ich das im Kicker gelesen. Und da hängen die Bayern mit drin. Und ich finde das eine sehr interessante Entwicklung. Ja, ja, das ist natürlich absolut katastrophal. Diese Multiclub-Ownership macht alles kaputt. Das nervt richtig. Ich meine, wir werden im Premier League-Segment gleich noch kurz über Everton sprechen. Also Triple Seven glaubt jetzt immerhin, dass sie bis Ende Januar den Kauf von Everton vervollständigen können. Aber man weiß gar nicht, was man sich da wünschen sollte. Gerade, wenn man weiß, woher Triple Seven sein Geld hat. Das habe ich in der letzten Folge, glaube ich, einen Podcast Double Pivot mit Liz Trustman aufgearbeitet. Die Bayern machen da jetzt aber mit, aber ein bisschen um die Ecke. Mit dieser Kooperation mit LFC, mit der eigenen Firma Red & Gold. Sollte man dann nämlich mal gegen die Grasshoppers spielen, in der Champions League wäre das kein Problem. Zumindest nach jetzigen Statuten. Bisher dürfen ja quasi zwei Teams des selben Anteils eigenes nicht gegeneinander spielen. Beziehungsweise wird es dann ganz, ganz schwierig. Oh Gott, was machen wir, wenn Salzburg gegen Leipzig spielt? Und de facto sind sie aber ja auf dem Papier gar nicht Anteil eigener von beiden. Naja, ich sehe schon. Da baut sich ein Tribügenspräch auf. Das wird auch irgendwann kommen, liebe Leute. Aber jetzt muss ich erstmal – Hat jemand von euch einen Kontakt zu Blackstone und CWC? Beziehungsweise – Nee, eigentlich zu dem will ich gar keinen Kontakt. Ich will einen Kontakt zu Journalistinnen, die sich sehr gut auskennen mit Blackstone und CWC. Über die würde ich gerne sprechen. Das ist das nächste Trümmergespräch, was gemacht werden muss. Ja, es sind gar nicht nur die Spiele des VfL Wolfsburg, die man manchmal darf.
Das ist, glaube ich, die Gesamtentwicklung des Fußballs, oder? Ganz ehrlich. Das ist ja das Multiclub ownership. Man merkt ja, dass das jetzt offenbar Nachahmer findet, denn die City Group ist da ja ganz berühmt dahinter und Red Bull ja auch, die beiden Vorreiter sozusagen. Und jetzt ziehen offenbar die ein oder andere nach. Chelsea will ja nachziehen mit Straßburg. Oder haben sie schon Straßburg aufgegeben? Einverleibt, ich weiß es gar nicht. Oder Ancheile, wie auch immer.
Du hast es indirekt auch durch die neuen Milliardäre, die sich kaufen, die ja dann oft irgendwelche zusammengeschlossenen Gruppen sind. Also da hätte man bei der Roma jetzt glaube ich auch nochmal. Die sind doch auch noch beteiligt an anderen Sport-Franchises, jetzt nicht im Fußball.
Genau, an anderen Sport-Franchises, genau.
Genau, und dann ist das aber der logische nächste Schritt, dass das kommen wird. Bisher gab es noch keine Synergieeffekte, die gut funktionieren haben, jenseits von eben dem Brausehersteller und jenseits von Manchester City. Ich glaube, da kann man es jetzt sagen mit Tyrona, und da gab es immer mal wieder, du kannst halt über Leihgeschäfte und so weiter ganz gut Spieler parken, Financial Fairplay umgehen und so weiter und so fort, und würden die natürlich nie machen. Die machen das natürlich nur for the good of the game, das ist mir schon klar, aber man könnte es machen.
In Südamerika übrigens, wenn ich kurz unterbrechen darf, hat die City Group einen Spieler gekauft. Also da war auch wirklich die Pressemitteilung oder die Social Power Ownership verboten. Na gut, wir erinnern uns an Carlos Tevez, Mascherano damals, als Sie von Südamerika nach zu West Ham oder wo sind sie hin? Genau, West Ham.
Da glaube ich waren es 70 oder 80 Prozent.
Da hat ja auch eine Firma die Rechte an den Spielern gekauft. Und jetzt hat die City Group, ich habe den Namen vergessen, ich kannte den auch nicht, irgendein Südamerikaner, ich weiß gar nicht woher, Uruguay, Argentinien, hat die City Group diesen Spieler unter Vertrag genommen. Und jetzt könnt ihr entscheiden, wohin schieben wir ihn. Schieben wir ihn nach New York City, nach Melbourne, nach, ich glaube, zur Show haben sie auch, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, zu Girona. Was machen wir denn mit ihm? Können sie sich jetzt aussuchen? Denn die City Group, die whole Ding sozusagen.
Ja, es ist ganz interessant, wenn man auf Italien blickt, da ist Italien noch einen Schritt zurück, was vielleicht in dem Fall ganz gut ist. Weil Italien ist jetzt so im Aufkommen, da schließt sich dann auch der Kreis zu unserem nächsten Thema. Juve und Atalanta sind die ersten Mannschaften, die überhaupt richtige, also zweite Mannschaften haben, die im Profibereich spielen. Also bis jetzt gab es immer die Primavera, das war ja sozusagen die letzte Stufe vor den Profis. Und da hat man halt im italienischen Fußball zuletzt gemerkt, dass dieser Sprung halt einfach oft zu gross war. Also dass gute Primavera-Spiele oder Herausragende dann oft trotzdem länger gebraucht haben, sozusagen bei den Profis Fuß zu fassen. Und Juve waren jetzt die ersten mit Juve NextGen, die spielen neben Liga Pro, also dritte Liga. Und was Juve in den letzten zwei Jahren da rausgezogen hat, an Talenten, die jetzt in Italien, also teilweise bei ihnen schon, das sind diese Solés, über den wir schon gesprochen haben, von Frosinone, Barinicea, also wirklich viele Spiele, auch die Fagiolis, Mirettis, die kommen alle da her. Und jetzt plötzlich in Italien nur alle, oh, das müssen wir nachziehen quasi. Also das ist ganz spannend. Da wird jetzt erstmal über den Weg gegangen. Atalanta, wie gesagt, der zweite Club, der sich jetzt auch eine Profi-Zweitmannschaft leistet, wo die Jungen zum Einsatz kommen. Also da sind wir im Moment noch weg von dieser Multi-Ownership.
Ja, das ist ja das Interessante. Also zum einen, es hat mit wenigen Ausnahmen noch nirgendwo Erfolg gehabt. Also schaut ihr alle Vereine von Triple Seven an. Die haben angeblich jede Woche oder jeden Monat alle Sportdirektoren gemeinsam call, um Wissen auszutauschen und Synergieeffekte zu nutzen. Ich habe gerade Anführungszeichnungen in die Luft gemalt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und schauen wir uns einfach mal an, wo stehen die Triple Seven Clubs? Ja, so wie vorher. Also bisher noch kein Effekt, jenseits von irgendwelchen – wir schieben meinen Spieler dorthin und dahin. Und das ist ja das, was das Ganze nochmal so besonders macht, finde ich. Dass, wenn du eine gute Jugendarbeit hast, die guten Fußballspieler, sie sind da. Wenn du sie gut ausbildest. Also es kann nicht sein, dass ein Land wie Italien irgendwo anders sich die Fußballspiele herziehen muss. Es kann nicht sein, dass ein Land wie Deutschland sich irgendwo anders die Fußballspiele herziehen muss. Wenn du eine sehr gute Nachwuchsarbeit hast und da auch vielleicht nicht alles so standardisierst, wie manche es machen, unter anderem der DFB, dann hast du eigentlich keine Sorgen. Du brauchst das eigentlich nicht. Aber weil sie das eben nicht hinbekommen und weil es nicht geil ist und weil es viel, viel länger dauert, weil der Sportdirektor, der da mal sagt, so, die Entscheidung treffen wir jetzt, wir machen das jetzt mal, wenn Juve nicht so einen schnellen Erfolg gehabt hätte, dann würde man wahrscheinlich da ganz anders drüber reden und erst in fünf Jahren oder so, dann kommen die ersten Spieler an. Es ist ja untypisch, dass es so schnell geht für diesen Bereich.
Aber Italien ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür, da hat sich ja in der Jugendarbeit in den letzten Jahren nicht maßgeblich was geändert. In Italien lag es wirklich daran, dass diese guten, talentierten Jugendspieler einfach über die Primavera vielleicht zu wenig gefordert waren. Und jetzt gibst du ihnen – was heißt zu wenig gefordert? Logisch hattest du immer wieder auch herausragende Talente, die dann direkt einen Weg zu den Profis gefunden haben. Aber ich sage mal, der Großteil, der dann vielleicht auch in der Primavera gut ausgesehen hat, hat sich dann extrem schwer getan, dann quasi auch in der Serie B oder so Fuß zu fassen. Und jetzt siehst du halt das Ergebnis bei Juve. Es sind wirklich viele Spieler. Also da reden wir jetzt nicht von zwei Dreien, sondern da reden wir jetzt über fünf, sechs, sieben. Selbst über Yildiz, zu dem wir jetzt gleich kommen. Der hat auch in der Juve Next-Gen erstmal seine ersten Schritte gemacht. Und da bist du dann halt einfach erstmal im Profibereich auch schon gefordert, kriegst einfach auch schon mal eine gewisse Härte mit. Und das scheint der Entwicklung dieser Spieler sehr gut zu tun. Die Ausbildung war genau dieselbe wie noch vor ein paar Jahren. Aber jetzt kommen sie anscheinend halt über den Profibereich sozusagen in einen Zwischenschritt rein, der ihnen für die Phase ihrer Karriere sehr hilfreich ist, um dann weiter oben auch Fuß fassen zu können.
Und ihr habt es nicht gemerkt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, aber wir wussten es schon längst, wir sind schon mitten im letzten Thema der Serie A. Nämlich bei diesem frischen Wind, der bei Juve jetzt weht. Unter anderem eben mit Kenan Yildiz, den ja eigentlich alle noch so halbwegs in Erinnerung haben sollten.
Genau, also wir hatten ja, ich glaube, über Juve haben wir logisch hier auch schon ein paar Mal gesprochen. Wenn ich mich recht erinnere, vor ein paar Wochen mal, da gings eben um das 1-0-Juve halt. Juve hinten defensiv stark, dann machen sie irgendwie einen Standard rein, gewinnen ihre Spiele. So, jetzt kann man wirklich, würde ich sagen, ein Monat, eineinhalb Monate später sagen, also die Ausgangslage ist weiterhin die, Juve ist komplett dran an Inter. Immer noch zwei Punkte nur dahinter, also hält den Rhythmus von Inter. Juve hat im Kalenderjahr 2024 vier Spiele bestritten und jetzt kommst du und dabei 15 Tore geschossen. Also 15 Tore in vier Spiele von Juve, ich weiß nicht, wann es das zuletzt mal gab. Jetzt muss man das ganze logischerweise einordnen. Diese vier Spiele waren zweimal gegen die Salernitana, einmal Frosinone und einmal Sassuolo. Also wir hatten da jetzt nicht die riesen Spiele, aber Juve hat auch in den Monaten davor und den Jahren zuvor gegen die Kleineren nicht zwei, drei, vier Buden gemacht. Zwei schon, aber sie hatten zuletzt mal ein Sechs-Tores-Spiel, sie hatten ein Viertores-Spiel. Jetzt haben sie am Dienstag in der Liga gegen Sassuolo 3-0 gewonnen. Zu dieser defensiven Stabilität ist jetzt auch gewisse offensive neue Elemente dazugekommen. Und warum ich es eben frischen Wind genannt habe, dann muss man wirklich, Yildiz ist so ein bisschen die Figur, die das am besten transportiert. Wir haben ihn ja von den Bayern quasi geholt, letztes Jahr schon. Wir haben ihn dann eben über die Next-Gen da erstmal ein bisschen eingearbeitet oder eingebaut. Und jetzt muss man wirklich sagen, in den letzten Wochen, also Allegri setzt regelmäßig auf ihn, hat jetzt eigentlich immer von Anfang an gespielt.
Von Anfang an sogar?
Ja, das lag logisch auch, hat auch damit zu tun, dass Kiesa zuletzt immer wieder mal ein bisschen muskuläre Probleme hatte. Aber er ist so ein bisschen sozusagen Kiesa oder Yildiz ist das Moment. Also es sind so ein bisschen ähnliche Spielertypen. Sie sind nicht eins zu eins gleich, denn Kiesa ist athletisch nochmal deutlich stärker. Kiesa ist so ein Tempo-Dribbler, also wenn der Raum hat, dann hältst du den nicht. Aber Yildiz bringt jetzt eben, also was Yildiz ist, muss man wirklich sagen, auf engen Raum. Also 1 gegen 1 Qualitäten, kaum Ballverluste, wirklich feine Technik, wirklich auch auf engen Raum mal was auflösen. Und das hat der Juwe so nicht, muss man sagen. Also Kiesa kommt mehr zur Geltung, wenn eben genau dieses Umschaltspiel da ist, wenn er Räume hat, wenn er attackieren kann, dann ist er wirklich auch athletisch kaum zu halten, wenn er fit ist. Und Yildiz bringt dir jetzt aber halt auch auf engen Raum sozusagen ein neues Element rein. Und er hat zuletzt getroffen jetzt zum ersten Mal, also sowohl im Pokal davor auch schon in der Liga. Und es ist wirklich jedes Spiel. Es gibt ein paar Yildiz-Momente im Spiel. Also es ist wirklich, den hat Alleghi richtig gut eingebaut. Und damit steht er so ein bisschen stellvertretend für diesen frischen Wind. Ich würde Cambiaso auch noch mitnehmen, ein Adria Cambiaso, junger Italiener, der war letztes Jahr ausgeliehen an Bologna. Und der spielt also unfassbar spielintelligent. So einen ganzen Fluiderspieler, den kannst du auf Außen bringen in dem 3-5-2, aber auch als Achter. Viel unterwegs, Reis, Träume, also einfach spielintelligent. Für mich sind Yildiz und Kambiasa so ein bisschen die Gesichter dieses frischen Windes. Du hast jetzt ein bisschen mehr Offensive. Schau dir die letzten Wochen an, diese 15 Tore, die Stürmer trafen plötzlich. Und dass bei Juve Qualität da ist, muss man nicht reden. Aber Wlauowitsch war halt monatelang, hat da Probleme gehabt, hat wenig getroffen, hatte auch körperliche Probleme, immer wieder ausgesetzt, war nicht ganz fit. Und jetzt hat Wlauowitsch die letzten drei Spiele entschieden. Er hat spät in Fosinone das 2-1-Entscheidene gemacht, er hat in Salerno in der Nachspielzeit das 2-1-Entscheidene gemacht und jetzt gegen Sassuolo das 1-0 und das 2-0 gemacht. Also Wlauowitsch hat wieder Selbstvertrauen, Milik hat in der Coppa Italia einen Dreierpack gemacht und Käse hat jetzt auch von der Bank gekommen getroffen und ist voll im Fluss quasi drin. Dieser bisschen offensiver Ansatz tut den Offensivspielern gut und dass Juwe da Qualität hat, müssen wir nicht darüber reden. Und dementsprechend, also ich finde es spannend, nochmal, wir müssen das Ganze einordnen, Frau Sinone, zwei Meister Lernitane, einmal Sassuolo, also da war jetzt kein Topspiel dabei. Aber du siehst so ein bisschen neue Elemente, dass aus dieser sehr guten defensiven Struktur, die ja weiterhin da ist, die aber zuletzt auch ein bisschen löchrig war, das hat der Lege auch immer wieder thematisiert und gesagt, wir müssen aufpassen, dass wir auch das Defensive schon nicht vergessen. Solche Sätze von Juve, glaube ich, unter Allegri, könnte man sich davor schwer vorstellen. Also es scheint so eine gewisse Weiterentwicklung da zu sein. Und ich bin sehr gespannt. Anfang Februar gibt es Inter gegen Juve, das direkte Duell. Jetzt am Wochenende, da Inter ja beim Supercup ist, könnte Juve sozusagen erst mal, zumindest mal vorbeiziehen. Klar, nur virtuell, aber es hätte vielleicht auch psychologisch Spaß, wenn dann Juve plötzlich mal vorne wäre. Und man merkt so dieses Juve-Inter, ich meine, das ist eines der großen Duellen, das jetzt eh schon medial wochenlang bedient wird. Aleger hat sich bis jetzt immer total zurückgehalten, immer gesagt, ach, unser Ziel ist Platz 4, Platz 4, wir haben 16 Punkte Vorsprung jetzt auf Platz 5, wunderbar, alles. Aber du merkst schon, die Spieler sprechen offensiver, da hörst du immer wieder mal jetzt auch das Wort Scudetto. Und ganz schön zum Abschluss, Aleger hat jetzt nach dem Sassuolo-Spiel, haben sie ihn halt auch auf diesen Zweikampf mit Inter angesprochen und ihn gefragt, wie er sich denn in der Rolle des Verfolgers fühlt. Und dann hat er so gemeint, hat er so ein bisschen gegrinst, hat er gesagt, ja gut, es ist ja immer so, es gibt ja auch, wenn der Dieb wegrennt, dann muss der Wachmann ja hinterher, sozusagen. Also es gibt immer welche, die halt vorne wegrennen, also er hat nicht das Hase-Igel-Beispiel gemeint, sondern er hat gemeint, ja, wenn der Dieb unterwegs ist, dann muss der Wachmann hinterher. Und ich glaube, es war im Moment so ein Spruch, den er einfach gebracht hat, aber logischerweise wird das Manual perfekt aufgegriffen. Wenn Allegri Inter als Dieb bezeichnet, dann hast du jetzt schon mal alles dargelegt, um die nächsten Wochen im Scudetto-2-Kampf zu darzulegen.
Deep Talk bei Allegri, hat die Grüße an Donny O'Sullivan, ist nicht mein Wort, Spiel. Aber das muss man wirklich nochmal sagen. Juwe, letzte Niederlage, Pflichtspielniederlage im September. Und Inter eben genauso gut. Also wenn Inter nicht genauso gut wäre, mit sogar einer noch besseren Abwehr. Ich meine, Inter hat 10 Gegentore in 20 Spielen. Juwe hatte 12 Gegentore in 20 Spielen. Aber ansonsten würden wir darüber sprechen, wie Juwe es geschafft hat, wieder zurückzukommen an die absolute Spitze. Also schon irre.
Aber es spricht sehr viel dafür, dass dieser Zweikampf wirklich sich weiter vorzieht. Denn Inter hat die Doppelblasen, jetzt Supercup, hat dann nochmal Nachholspiel, weil jetzt eins verschoben wurde, hat die Champions League und Juwe hat das eben alles nicht. Juwe konzentriert sich von Woche zu Woche, der Flow ist da und sie wirken im Moment wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr stabil.
Absolut. Und ich muss vielleicht noch einordnen, warum ich gesagt habe, jeder kennt Kenan Yildiz, vielleicht war das dann doch nicht jedem klar. Der hat dieses krasse, krass geile 2 zu 1 gegen Deutschland geschossen. Im Olympiastadion. Kurz vor der Halbzeit, das war dieser Seitenwechsel, er legt den Ball vorbei und zimmert ihn in den kurzen Winkel. Und ich meine klar, wenn man irgendwie ganz krasser Deutschlandfan ist, dann hat das natürlich wehgetan, aber es war ein wunderbares Tor. Und der hat sich eben auch für die türkische Nationalmannschaft entschieden. Und dementsprechend wurde das, glaube ich, nochmal besonders gefallen.
Also Yiliz ist wirklich sehr spannend. Also das ist wirklich ein Spielertyp, der Juve-Extremement gut tut und allein Yiliz jetzt auch noch zu haben in diesem Mix mit Milik, Vlaović und Keza, ist ein gutes Plus.
Meine Güte, und den hat Bayern gehen lassen, das sehe ich ja schon. Die kommenden Geschichten, aber die sollen dann andere machen. Wir machen jetzt nämlich nur noch unsere Awards. Wir wollen noch MVP an Sang Hero und Moment der letzten Wochen in den beiden verbleibenden Ligen noch küren. Und da darf Alex gerne mal anfangen. Wer ist denn dein MVP?
MVP ist Antoine Griezmann. Muss man hier einfach mal jetzt erst recht betiteln. Ich glaube, ich habe ihn in der Vergangenheit schon gelobt, als im Kalender ja bester Spieler der Liga. Aber irgendwie wird das in Awards, die man ja kennt, FIFA the best, Ballon d'Or, wird das irgendwie nie so richtig…
Ja, ich bin enttäuscht, dass du nicht mit Lionel Messi kommst.
Honoriert, der spielt ja nicht mehr in La Liga, ist ja nicht mehr mein Thema.
Er sollte auch nicht um die WM gehen bei dieser Quatschabstrugung.
Anderes Thema. Ich wollte nur sagen, Griezmann, so stark er in La Liga ist, wird er da einfach, ja, das wird nicht honoriert, das wird nicht wiedergespielt in Ballon d'Or und anderen Awards, wo er trotzdem immer 25. ist etc. Aber jetzt hat er trotzdem die Schlagzeilen bestimmt, zumindest etwas mehr als sonst, denn er ist neuer Rekordtorschützer in der Vereinshistorie Athleticus, sein 174. Tor geschossen, damit Vereinslegende Luis Aragones, der ja auch Trainer war, überflügelt, der 173 hatte leider, in Anführungszeichen, hat er das nur bei der Supercoppa gemacht, nicht in einem Ligaspiel, sprich, so um die Welt ging es auch nicht, denn zum Beispiel Max schaut ja keine Supercoppa.
Aber immerhin passt in der Weise. Aber ich bin sicher, die saudi-arabischen Fans haben das richtig honoriert, oder? Die sind da steil gegangen mit Corio und allem.
Das ist ja genau mein Punkt. Das wäre natürlich viel schöner. So ein besonderer Meilenstein, dass man den in der Liga optimalerweise vielleicht sogar in einem Heimspiel, im Metropolitano erreicht, wäre nochmal besonderer als in Saudi-Arabien, wo kaum jemand zuschaut, wo kaum jemand das mitbekommt. Deswegen sage ich ja, ein bisschen schade ist es. Immerhin der Anlass war trotzdem recht nice, denn er hat im Derby Madrileño, also im Madridter Stadttorbi gegen Real Madrid, da hat er sein 174. Tor geschossen. Verloren haben sie aber trotzdem. Passt irgendwie auch ein bisschen zu. Das stimmt allerdings wirklich. Auf jeden Fall, ja. Moment der letzten Wochen oder MVP. Also ich nehme mal beide Awards zusammen, Antoine Griezmann.
Okay, und der Moment ist dann das Tor, das er geschossen hat. Ja, und ich sehe, du hast es kommen sehen, denn du hattest Antoine Griezmann schon am 30. November in der Ligatur als MVP. Du hast es gekollt. Sehr schön, in denen scheinst du dich verguckt zu haben. Ich verstehe aber auch, warum. Wen müssen wir denn in der Serie A oder wen wollen wir da besonders hervorheben, Christian?
Also klar, man könnte jetzt, ich habe es hier vorhin schon angedeutet, man könnte jetzt Blauowitsch nehmen, weil er zuletzt wieder heiß war. Aber nein, ich nehme Alessandro Bon giorno. Und das ist der Kapitän von Torino. Ja, sehr schöner Name und auch sehr guter Fußballer. Innenverteidiger, Kapitän bei Toro – die Vorgeschichte ist die – im Sommer hat er in Torino schon Atalanta verkauft. Atalanta immer auf der Suche nach Talentierten. Nicht nur Talentierten, Bon giorno ist mehr als nur talentiert. Er war sich einig mit Torino, aber dann hat er sich gesagt, er möchte bleiben, er möchte als Kapitän in Torino bleiben. Er ist da geblieben und jetzt ist Torino im Dunstkreis der Europa-Parkal-Platze. Nur ein Punkt hinter der Roma, hat, glaube ich, nur vier Punkte Rückstand. Auch noch sozusagen im Rennen um die Champions League Ränge sogar, hat in den letzten 7 Spielen nur zwei Gegentore kassiert. Und Bongiorno ist wirklich nicht nur der Kapitän, sondern auch der Abwehrchef in der Dreierkette. Er hat sich in dieser Saison – er übernimmt jetzt die zentrale Rolle – zuletzt war Pierre Schürs, der Holländer, der leider die ganze Saison verletzungsbedingt ausfällt, sozusagen hat den Part jetzt übernommen und ist einfach das Synonym für diese Stabilität von Torino. Er hat auch schon dreimal getroffen, also selbst bei Standards gefährlich. Und jetzt im Winter ging es wieder los. Napoli will unbedingt, Milan will jetzt auch unbedingt. Aber ich glaube, Torino ist ja gerade jetzt im Winter, die bleiben jetzt erstmal standhaft. Und vielleicht hat er noch nicht vielen etwas gesagt. Das könnte sich im Sommer ändern. Spalletti hat ihn, der Nationaltrainer, beim entscheidenden Spiel gegen die Ukraine hat er ihn etwas überraschend von Anfang an gebracht. Da hat er ja auch zu Null gespielt. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass Bon Giorno nächstes Jahr, also jetzt im Sommer, auch auf der großen Bühne, mehr Aufmerksamkeit bekommt.
Ich würde ja gerne mal einen Bayernwitz von vorhin wiederholen, aber den kennen die auf gar keinen Fall. Das ist viel zu weit weg. Da muss man einmal über die Alpen drüber gucken.
Das ist auch hoch, da drüber über die Alpen. Das sind diese Berge.
Das ist auf gar keinen Fall der Fall. Wer ist denn dein Unsung Hero, Alex?
Ich nenne mal einen Spieler, den vielleicht auch ganz wenige auf dem Schirm haben, vielleicht auch niemand hierzulande. Alvaro Valles, der Torhüter von Las Palmas. Ich glaube, über Las Palmas wurde in der letzten Ligatour gesprochen vom Kollegen Pakulat, bin mir nicht sicher.
Genau, stimmt.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob er ihn genannt hat. Auf jeden Fall ist er der Aufsteiger, um es kurz zusammenzufassen. Nach vielen, vielen Jahren sind sie endlich wieder in die Primära Division. Sie sind mittlerweile neunter. Der Platz und der Rang sind an sich schon ein schönes Achievement. Viel bemerkenswerter ist, dass ich glaube, 13 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Abstiegsplatz und nur vier Rückstand auf Rang 6 auf die Europa Cup Plätze. Das zeigt schon auf, dass sie eine gute Saison spielen, mit schönem Fußball, Ballbesitz etc. Und einen großen Anteil, dass die so gut sind, hat der Torhüter Váez, der zu den besten Torhütern der Liga gehört. Vielleicht sogar statistisch gesehen, der Beste ist fünfmal zu null gespielt, haben ein paar andere Torhüter mehr. Aber absolut bemerkenswert hat er eine Safe-Percentage von 81 %. Wer sich mit diesen statistischen Metriken auskennt, alles über 80 ist absolut herausragend. Also ganz wenige Spieler weltweit haben die Acht vorne. Und wenn du da als Torhüter 80 % oder mehr hast, das ist absolut herausragend. Auch bemerkenswert ist, dass er schon 11, 3 Tore verhindert hat. Also XG gibt es ja nicht nur für Stürmer, sondern auch für Torhüter 11, 3 Tore verhindert.
Auf Platz 2 ist er real mit 5, 2.
Auf Rang 2 ist David Zoria von Retafel mit 4, 8.
Ich bin bei FB Reef, du bist vor allem.
Ich bin bei Fondmorpub, die Statistik-Seiten unterscheiden sich minimal, aber der zweitbeste Torhüter hat 5 Tore verhindert und er hat 11 Tore verhindert. Also eigentlich anders gerechnet hätte Las Palmas vielleicht 11 Tore mehr kassieren müssen, um es jetzt mal so zusammenzufassen. Also absolut bemerkenswert und auch bei den gehaltenen Bällen pro Spiel hält er 3, 7 Bälle pro Spiel. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein Top-3-Wert in La Liga. Also du merkst schon, bei diesen Individualmetriken ist er ganz, ganz oben mit dabei. Und deswegen ein bisschen der Unsung Hero. Spielt eine richtig, richtig starke Saison.
Stark, sehr, sehr gut. Und ich hab die Post-Shot-Expected-Ghosts angeguckt. Daher dürfte der Unterschied kommen. Aber in beiden absolut herausragend.
Er ist schon ein bisschen nerdig.
Ja, es gibt schon einen Grund, warum du hier zusammen mit all deinen Kollegen in der Ligatur bist. Es passt halt ganz gut. Rasenfunk und das hier. Ihr ertragt ja auch alle meine Bundesliga-Referenzen. Jetzt werden wir noch einen Helden in Italien besingen. Und dann darfst du direkt einen Moment hinterher schieben, bei dem von Alex Hamberschen eingesammelt wird.
Ja, Ansang, da möchte ich jetzt schonmal Massimiliano Allegri hernehmen. Also der hat ja, wenn wir den besungen haben, dann haben wir den ja monatelang oder jahrelang eher Klagelied-mäßig besungen. Und ja, wir haben es vorhin angesprochen, Juve ist voll im Sol, Juve ist dran. Also nicht nur im Sol, sondern ich würde sogar sagen mehr. Und das hat logisch viel mit Allegri zu tun, weil er es geschafft hat. Ich würde mal sagen, das, was er in seiner ersten Phase bei Juve, was sie ihn ausgemacht hat als Juve-Serienmeister war, als Juve logischerweise auch personell nochmal ganz andere Qualität hatte. Aber Allegri hat es halt immer geschafft, wirklich so ein Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl, ein Mannschaftsgefühl zu kreieren. Und das ist jetzt dieses Jahr wieder da. Also die letzten zwei Jahre von Allegri hatten wir oft thematisiert, waren enttäuschend, brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden. Wobei man auch – das letzte Jahr muss man noch dazufügen – er hätte sich eigentlich für die Champions League qualifiziert als Vierter, also sportlich gesehen. Aber jetzt, was er diese Saison macht, es ist wirklich eine extreme Einheit. Wir hatten es thematisiert. Am Anfang diese defensive Stabilität, die ist da. Jetzt wird ein bisschen weiterentwickelt. Und du siehst es halt an vielen kleinen Momenten, zum Beispiel Blauwich und Chiesa, die eigentlich das Einzerpärchen im Sturm sind vom Namen her. Die waren jetzt ganz oft auf der Bank, oder zumindest einer auf der Bank. Und immer, wenn sie reingekommen sind, haben sie funktioniert. Die haben auch von der Bank geliefert. Blauwich hat dieses 2-1 gegen Frosinone von der Bank kommend erzielt. Chiesa hat von der Bank kommend getroffen und Momente kreiert. Und das sind so Zeichen, wo du merkst, die Mannschaft ist ein extrem eingeschworener Haufen. Und da ist Juve gefährlich. Und genau da hat er sie hingebracht. Plus eben, hat man vorhin auch schon angedeutet, diese jungen Elemente mit reingebracht. Yildiz allen voran, Campiaso, auch Gatti, den wir ja auch schon hier thematisiert hatten. Also es scheint, als sei ihm gelungen, dass Juve wirklich diese extreme Juve-Einheit wieder ist. Und wie gesagt, die Tabelle sagt es her. Er ist mittendrin, auch wenn Inter für mich oder für die allermeisten einfach der Favorit bleibt. Aber solange Juve dran ist, wird es unangenehm für Inter sein. Und deshalb finde ich, hat sich das Allegri nach vielen, vielen negativen Dingen absolut mal verdient.
Aber wirklich, Gatti war doch der, der Mauern gebaut hat als Bauarbeiter und dann doch in den Profifußball gekommen ist. Sehr schön. Und was ist dann der Moment der letzten Woche?
Ja, der Moment habe ich mich dafür entschieden. Am vergangenen Spieltag Milan gegen die Roma, was eben das letzte Spiel von Herrn Mourinho war. 3-1 Sieg von Milan, wo Milan wirklich auch wieder gezeigt hat. Sie sind auch wieder auf dem Weg zurück. Sie haben jetzt in den letzten acht Spielen sechs gewonnen, nur eins verloren. Also haben sie dieses Champions League aus verkraftet. Sie sind jetzt klar, der Rückstand zu Inter und Juve ist schon ein bisschen groß. Aber sie haben einen großen Vorsprung auf den Rest. Also sie sind wieder an der Spur. Und es gab das 3-1, wirklich großartiges Tor. Schaut es euch gerne an, falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt. Theo Hernandez auf Hackenzuspiel von Olivier Giroud. Hernandez im Lauf, Giroud wunderbar, richtig gelesen, legt ihn in den Lauf. Und Theo Hernandez zimmert ihn unter den Balken, wie man glaube ich so schön sagt. Und ich habe es deswegen auch genommen, nicht nur weil es ein schönes Tor ist, sondern weil es auch bei Milan die letzten Wochen hatten wir auch schon wahnsinnig viele Verletzte, gerade in der Verteidigung. Und deswegen ist Theo Hernandez – jetzt über mehrere Wochen war er Innenverteidiger – hat das eben gut gemacht, weil Milan da unter ihm auch viele Siege jetzt wieder eingefahren hat. Aber jetzt dieses Spiel war jetzt das erste, wo er wieder als Linksverteidiger gespielt hat. Und Theo Hernandez plus Leao zusammen über Links, das hatten wir auch schon ein paar Mal, ist eine gewisse Qualität dahinter. Die hat er jetzt hier wieder gezeigt. Und ein Satz noch, ich glaube, ich habe auch schon ein paar Mal über Giroud gesprochen. Ich muss es jedes Mal wiederholen. Für mich, Giroud, ich glaube, er wird jetzt 37. Also klar, er hat sein Alter. Aber für mich, Giroud weiterhin einer der Spielintelligentesten Neuner, die es gibt. Also es gibt in jedem Spiel, ich habe das Glück, immer wieder Milan Spiele kommentieren zu dürfen, es gibt in jedem Spiel Momente, die nur Giroud durch seinen cleveren Laufweg, durch sein Abschirmen und eben nicht nur das Abschirmen. Ich finde, es gibt viele Mittelstürmer, die gut den Ball abdecken, aber Giroud hat dann halt auch noch diese Kreativität, diesen letzten Pass zu spielen. Und dieses Beispiel hier mit Theo Ananas war perfekt, mit der Hacke, in den Lauf, wunderbar. Also Giroud für mich weiterhin Mittelstürmer Masterclass.
Ach Olivier Giroud, da kommen wir wirklich ins Schwärmen geraten, aus ganz ganz vielen Gründen. Ich danke euch beiden sehr, danke dir, lieber Alex. Und danke dir, lieber Christian. Und dann werde ich mich in wenigen Minuten bedanken bei Jogi Hebel. Mit dem geht es jetzt nämlich weiter. Jogi Hebel ist jetzt hier. Jogi, servus, schön, dass du da bist.
Hallo, grüß dich. Vielen Dank, ich danke für die Einladung.
Ich habe vorhin mit den anderen drüber gesprochen zum Einstieg, wie das eigentlich so ist, wenn man über eine Liga berichtet, die keine Winterpause hat. Das Extrembeispiel war dann gar nicht anwesend. Wie ist denn das so als Reporter? Ich habe mich ja über die paar freien Tage durchaus gefreut, die ich jetzt hatte. Und wie war es bei dir?
Bei uns war jetzt auch so Players Break, nennt man es in England. Da ist dann viel FA Cup und EFL Cup, was für mich dann kein Thema war. Ich persönlich muss sagen, diese Dezemberzeit ist für mich immer die schönste, weil da halt wirklich der volle Fokus auf die Premier League ist. Deswegen würde ich es eher umgekehrt sehen. Ich nehme das dann eher immer als Freudigen an, dass ich sagen kann, okay, da schauen dann wirklich alle und man sieht es dann auch als Highlight. Wenn ich heute ein Spiel habe, dann weiß ich, die Zuschauer werden wahrscheinlich 25 Prozent mehr sein oder wie auch immer. Das heißt, ich habe immer eine schöne Zeit.
Okay, ich sehe schon. Dann bist du trotzdem auch gut erholt, weil du einfach mit guter Laune durch die Arbeit hindurchgerauscht bist. Jetzt haben wir dann logischerweise schon länger nicht mehr über die Premier League gesprochen. Das Tabellenbild nur einmal, damit das kurz erwähnt ist. Liverpool aktuell vorne mit zwei Punkten Vorsprung vor City und vor Villa. Aber Villa hat schon ein Spiel mehr. 45 Punkte Liverpool, 43 City, 43 Eston Villa, dann Arsenal mit 40, Tottenham mit 40 und danach gibt es den Cut. Und alles andere haben wir ja zum Teil schon in der vergangenen Zeit besprochen und werden wir noch besprechen. Heute wollen wir mal blicken auf mögliche Strafen. Und dann werden wir auch nochmal über City sprechen. Was droht denn da schon wieder am Horizont, Jogi?
Ja, das ist eben die große Frage. So genau weiß es noch keiner. Also es ist im Endeffekt nur bestätigt worden, dass für Nottingham Forest und für Everton Strafen drohen, dass sie gegen die Financial Fairplay Regeln der Premier League verstoßen haben. Everton hat das ja schon mal getan. Die haben schon zehn Punkte abgezogen bekommen. Was muss man sagen, eine historische Strafe ist. Wenn wir uns daran erinnern, Portsmouth, die haben mal neun Punkte abgezogen bekommen. Da waren die aber eigentlich insolvent. Also ist es schon eine heftige Strafe. Und jetzt droht ihnen erneut ein Punktabzug, weil eben wieder Verluste eingefahren worden sind. Bei Lothar Hingham genau dasselbe. Da war es irgendwie zu erwarten. Und dann ist natürlich jetzt die ganz große Frage, was passiert? Gibt es wirklich eine Strafe? Gibt es nur eine finanzielle Strafe, dass man nochmal irgendwas zahlen muss? Gibt es wirklich einen Punktabzug? Transfer sperren wir auch immer. Da ist dann alles möglich. Das ist noch nicht so genau klar. Aber es drohen auf jeden Fall Strafen. Das ist klar. Das ist schon so durchgeklungen. Die Frage ist dann einfach nur noch die Höhe. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, die sich daraus dann dreht. Was passiert mit Chelsea? Was passiert mit Newcastle? Was passiert mit Man City? Kann man das alles vergleichen? Und so weiter und so fort. Also es gibt da Themen ohne Ende momentan. Und vor allem, das haben wir im Podcast auch besprochen, es ist halt super verrückt, dass eigentlich das Land des Turbo-Kapitalismus, die Premier League, die eigentlich so viel Geld ausgeben, wie kaum ein anderes Land in den letzten Jahren, die eigentlich auch so nachlässig waren, wie kaum ein anderes Land, dass die plötzlich hergehen und auf, also wirklich überall hingreifen, wo es nur irgendwie geht. Das persönlich war für uns auch alle neu.
Ja, und gleichzeitig ist ja auch die Frage dann, ob das Instrumentarium, was man sich da zurechtgelegt hat, ob das dann wirklich an den richtigen Stellen eingreift. Also ich habe jetzt auch Diskussionen darüber gelesen. Es geht ja, verkürzt gesagt, korrigiere mich bitte, wenn ich es mir falsch gemerkt habe, aber verkürzt gesagt, geht es darum, du hast eine gewisse Höhe deiner Einnahmen und dementsprechend darfst du nur eine gewisse Menge an Transferausgaben haben. Und wenn du darüber liegst, über einen nennenswerten Zeitraum, da gab es ja noch so drei Kulanzjahre gerade wegen Corona, während Corona, aber dann kann es eben zu Strafen wie eben Punktabzügen kommen. Und da muss man jetzt kein mathematisches Genie sein, um zu sehen, naja, das bevorteilt ja eigentlich erst mal die reichen Clubs, nämlich eben Manchester City und so weiter und so fort, weil die haben eben so viele hohe Einnahmen, dass sie dann sehr viel Spielraum auf der Transferseite haben. Und wir merken es ja jetzt auch, wenn es einen Club wie Nottingham jetzt zum Beispiel treffen würde. Wir alle haben gesehen, was die auf dem Transfermarkt gemacht haben. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die da unschuldig reingerutscht sind. Aber auf der anderen Seite, warum haben sie das denn gemacht? Ja, du steigst auf oder du etablierst dich gerade am unteren Ende der Liga und willst einfach den Abstieg verhindern, der so dramatisch ist aus der Premier League in die Champions League trotz aller Parachute, also falschen Zahlungen. Also es scheint auch so ein bisschen schief zu sein, weil die Teams, wo man eigentlich denken würde, die kann man ja auch mal gerne beschrafen. Manchester City zum Beispiel, werden wir zwar auch gleich noch mal drüber reden, aber so richtig hart trifft die wahrscheinlich dann doch eher wieder nicht.
Genau, absolut. Vor allem habe ich letztens einen sehr interessanten Vortrag gesehen von David Ornstein von Athletic, der genau das beschrieben hat, was du gerade sagst, der es zusammengefasst hat mit. Bei Everton zum Beispiel war es so, die haben über Jahre hinweg Verluste gemacht. Und das Problem ist, sie haben sportlich durch diese Verluste, die sie gemacht haben, keinen Vorteil gehabt. Also zum Beispiel, angenommen sie wären jetzt dritter geworden jedes Mal, dann hätte man gesagt, naja gut, es ist ja wenigstens Wert entstanden. Sportlicher Wert, finanzieller Wert, durch die Spieler wie auch immer. Dann hätte man mehr Nachsicht walten lassen, als wenn man sagt, naja gut, die Strugglen hat einfach jedes Jahr, da sind die kurzer vorab zu steigen, die wollen noch mal alles raushauen, um in der Liga zu bleiben, um die Einnahmen zu garantieren. Das wird denen dann als Nachteil oder als negativ ausgelegt, dass sie dann strampeln quasi im Endeffekt. Und das macht es dann irgendwie auch noch mal verrückter, dass dann Everton noch mehr bestraft wird, weil sie eben sagen, wir wollen unbedingt in der Liga bleiben. Das ist sehr, sehr verrückt insgesamt das Ganze.
Ja, wobei andererseits kann man da natürlich auch argumentieren, genau bei solchen Clubs passieren dann die finanziell richtigen Dramen, weil du eben dann versuchst, den Abstieg zu verhindern und dann steigst du dennoch ab. Ich meine, da haben wir genügend Beispiele aus allen Ligen, dass das das ist, was einen ganzen Verein killen kann. Und das haben wir ja tatsächlich in der Premier League auch schon erlebt, bzw. in den unteren Ligen. Da haben wir ja mal diese Sonderfolge zu Bolton gemacht, zu Almeria und der dritte Case fällt mir gerade nicht mehr ein. Aber da sind quasi innerhalb von wenigen Wochen Vereine quasi einfach letztlich komplett aus dem Vereinsregister gelöscht worden, muss noch mal ganz unten wieder anfangen. Also es ergibt schon irgendwie Sinn, regulativ einzugreifend. Andererseits finde ich es aber auch ein bisschen schwer, dass aktuell zumindest immer noch so schwierig abzuschätzen ist, was jetzt passiert. Also wir haben die Everton den Punktabzug, wenn euch das interessiert, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das war die Ligatour vom 30.11. Da hat Hendrik Buchheister damals auch darüber gesprochen. Ja, ein bisschen wirkt das auch so, als soll da jetzt ein Exempel statuiert werden und eben gezeigt werden, so, jetzt greifen wir richtig durch. Wenn das jetzt bei Nottingham und nochmal Everton wieder so ist, okay, dann etabliert sich so langsam Maßstab. Aber es ist sehr schwer, irgendwie abzuschätzen, was da jetzt passiert, was eben die mögliche Höhe der Strafe angeht.
Absolut, das ist das eine Ding. Und auf der anderen Seite, wir kriegen ja dann logischerweise auch Zuschriften bei Instagram, wie auch immer, oder auch bei Twitter. Und die erste Reaktion war halt, das ist jetzt völlig fern von jeder Realität, von irgendwelchen Ermessensspielräumen. Aber du kriegst natürlich sofort, ja, dann bin ich gespannt, was mit Newcastle passiert. Ja, dann bin ich gespannt, was mit Chelsea passiert. Ja, dann bin ich gespannt, was mit City passiert. Das kannst du alles nicht vergleichen. Aber du kannst dem Fan halt auch nicht verkaufen. Everton und Nottingham kriegen es ab. Und die anderen kriegen momentan erst mal gar nichts. Und das ist halt das große, das ist das, was die Diskrepanz nicht meinte, dass diese kleinen Vereine, dass der Fan da draußen das Gefühl bekommt, die kleinen Vereine bekommen es ab. Und City bekommt irgendwie 100.000 Euro Strafe, und dann ist das Ding weg. Nochmal, diese Fälle kann man nicht vergleichen. Jeweils nicht vergleichen. Das ist jetzt alles nicht derselbe Tatbestand. Aber das muss, glaube ich, der Zuschauer draußen, der jetzt vielleicht meistens La Liga schaut, vielleicht der dann auch einmal auf die Premier League schaut, der muss das nicht verstehen. Und dann zum Beispiel, wenn man dann den ganz großen Bogen zieht auf andere Vereine wie Barcelona, die Schulden haben ohne Ende, da passiert dann nichts und so weiter und so fort. Also das kann man dann auch auf den europäischen Kosmos ausweiten. Dass jetzt plötzlich in der Premier League, die auch jahrelang überall weggeschaut haben, jetzt wird zugegriffen, in anderen Ländern wird nicht zugegriffen, in der Bundesliga zum Beispiel, sind sie verhältnismäßig immer schon streng, dann aber wieder, naja, gut, es gibt einen Gnadengesuck und so weiter. Es ist einfach alles halt irgendwie so ein bisschen verrückt. Wer wann wo wieves halt warum. Und das ausgerechnet die Premier League jetzt so zu packt, das ist halt wirklich komplett neu.
Ja, ich meine, grundsätzlich finde ich das mal sehr interessant, wenn da eben mal genauer drauf geguckt wird. Aber eben du sagst es, es ist nicht zu vergleichen. Also Barca hat zwar Schulden ohne Ende, Barca hat aber halt auch die Gewinne der nächsten zehn Jahre verkaufen können. Und es ist sehr richtig anzunehmen, dass die wahrscheinlich auch Gewinne haben werden. Und das ist etwas anderes, wenn das zum Beispiel Everton machen würde. Wenn die die Gewinne der nächsten zehn Jahre verkaufen und dann aber absteigen, dann beginnen nämlich die richtigen Probleme. Und Newcastle zum Beispiel ist ein gutes Beispiel. Also ich bin zahlender Kunde bei Swiss Rumble. Das ist ja Kieran McGuire, der immer – nee, nicht McGuire, nein, Kieran heißt auf jeden Fall mit Vornamen – der so die Wirtschaftsberichterstattung auf so ein neues Level gehoben hat. Und gerade bei der Premier League sind die Artikel immer ellenlang. Den zu Newcastle habe ich auch nicht komplett gelesen, ich gebe es zu. Den zu Nottingham Forest jetzt gerade auch nur nochmal ganz schnell überflogen, damit ich im Thema bin. Aber der arbeitet das dann immer sehr genau raus. Und da siehst du dann aber eben auch, so jemand wie Newcastle hat einen größeren Spielraum. Es ist nicht vergleichbar zur Everton-Situation, nicht vergleichbar zur Nottingham-Position, wird aber sehr wahrscheinlich auch bei Newcastle zu marken sein, weil das Financial Fairplay bezieht sich immer auf die letzten drei Jahre. Das heißt, Newcastle kam von einem relativ guten Fundament, haben dann ihre großen Ausgaben gehabt. Und er kommt eben hier zu dem Fazit, was Newcastle angeht. Also die werden sehr sicher Spieler verkaufen müssen. So werden die nicht weitermachen können. Das heißt, es ist was, was in der Zukunft liegt. Das heißt, man kann es auch immer erst im Rückblick dann mit mehreren Jahren Abstand eigentlich bewerten. Und das macht es aber schwierig für uns. Und das ist eben jetzt Everton und Nottingham. Bei Everton kommt ja noch das Thema mit dazu, dass Triple Seven die kaufen möchte. Triple Seven hat jetzt gesagt, bis Ende Januar soll das durch sein. Das ist auch so ein komischer Prozess, dass man gar nicht so genau weiß, wann prüft die Premier League das, wann sind sie denn jetzt endlich fertig mit ihrer Prüfung. Erlebst du das auch als so ein bisschen, man tappt da ständig im Nebel?
Ja, aber die Schwierigkeit ist halt eben das, da ist vielleicht auch dann die Brücke zu City, dass dieser Nebel ja nicht unbedingt von der Premier League verschuldet ist, sondern teilweise von den Vereinen auch. Weil zum Beispiel, Everton hat ja den ersten Punktabzug bekommen, weil sie es zugegeben haben. Sie haben gesagt, wir haben das getan, hier sind unsere Papiere, schaut mal rein. Das und das haben wir falsch gemacht, da haben wir zu viel ausgegeben. Wir haben das auch erkannt, deswegen haben wir zum Beispiel Anthony Gordon verkauft, hätten wir sonst vielleicht nicht gemusst, hätten wir sonst vielleicht nicht getan. Also das heißt, wir haben das erkannt, wir geben das zu, wir wüssten, wir würden sonst eine höhere Strafe kriegen, wir geben es zu, bitte bestraft und jetzt sanfter in Anführungszeichen. Dementsprechend ist dieser Case abgeschlossen mit den zehn Punkten. City zum Beispiel sagt, wir haben nichts getan, wir wissen überhaupt nicht, wovon ihr redet. Wenn ihr etwas gegen uns erhebt an Vorwürfen, dann tut das bitte, aber uns geht das nichts an. Dementsprechend zieht sich das länger. Dementsprechend denkt der Zuschauer draußen aber, City wird nicht bestraft. Nur die Kleinen trifft es immer. Das ist halt auch die Diskrepanz an den ganzen Geschichten, dass manche halt mitarbeiten und manche halt nicht. Und Everton dachte, sie würden verhältnismäßig sanfter vorkommen, bekommen dann aber die zehn Punkte hingeklatscht und kriegen sie jetzt vielleicht nochmal. Und dann kommt natürlich diese Fallhöhe wieder dazu, dass dann alle sagen, naja, wenn Everton zehn Punkte bekommt, City aber 115 Anklagepunkte hat, dann sind wir mal gespannt, was da passiert. Jetzt, wenn aber dann rauskommt, bei City, ja, das war ein und derselbe Tatbestand, 73 Mal und dann noch ein anderer und die kriegen zwei Punkte abgezogen oder vielleicht eine Strafe von einer Million. Mach mal 20, mach mal 10, ist ja egal wieviel. Dann wird der Zuschauer wieder sagen, ich kann das nachvollziehen. Du kannst alles, du kannst die Sachen nicht vergleichen. Du kannst auch dann im Endeffekt die Tatbestände nicht vergleichen. Du kannst auch die Strafen dann logischerweise nicht vergleichen. Und das macht es halt dann wieder so schwierig. Im Endeffekt nehme ich da nicht raus, wenn ich die Berichte nicht lese oder nicht eben mit David Ons den anhöre, sondern eben einfach nur von draußen auf das ganze Blick gedehnke ich mir auch. Ja klar, die Kleine erwischt es wieder. Das ist ja in der Champions League genau selbe gewesen. Der FC Sion wird ausgeschlossen, bei City heißt es, ach zahlt uns und das Ganze wird unter den Tisch gekehrt. Das ist halt dann immer dieser fahre Beigeschmack, der bleibt halt irgendwo immer und das ist dann vielleicht auch rational gar nicht zu erklären.
Und glaubst du, was eben jetzt die Anklage von Manchester City angeht, dass das noch in dieser Saison entschieden wird?
Also es heißt, was man so liest, oder es kam gestern der Bericht, dass eine Anhörung jetzt angesetzt ist. Das heißt in nächster Zeit. Es steht nicht genau das Datum, aber man geht davon aus, was ich jetzt gelesen habe, Ende Februar, dass City mal gehört wird. Und dann ist natürlich auch die Frage, was sagen die? Also alles, was sie jetzt gesagt haben, die City Group, war so quasi, wir wissen überhaupt nicht, wovon ihr redet. Und das ist halt dann wieder ein Zeichen dafür, dass sich das eher noch mal ziehen könnte. Verjährt dann was, verschleiert sich irgendwas, kriegen die irgendwie die Möglichkeit, irgendwas zu verschleiern. Das ist dann wieder die Frage, die man sich stellen muss. Und dann ist natürlich auch, das ist dann wirklich Zukunftsmusik, aber Guardiola sagte, wenn ihr mich angelogen habt, also die Citigroup, wenn ihr mich angelogen habt und ihr habt doch etwas getan, dann bin ich weg. Weil er hat sich hingestellt und hat gesagt, mir wurde erzählt, es ist nichts passiert, es ist nichts getan worden, was irgendwie falsch war. Dementsprechend habe ich hier ein reines Gewissen, sollten die mich angelogen haben, dann bin ich weg. Das hat er öffentlich gesagt. Auch das ist natürlich Zukunftsmusik, aber es ist sehr interessant dann zu sehen, wie würde Pep Guardiola reagieren, wenn wirklich rauskäme, City hat sich falsch verhalten. City bekommt einen Punktabzug, bekommt eine fette Strafe. Sie waren es dann doch, oder wie auch immer. Das ist dann natürlich die große Frage, was passieren würde.
Na gut, wir haben gerade im La Liga-Segment gehört, Xavi wackelt bei Barca. Das könnte ja dann vielleicht was sein. Aber jetzt warten wir erstmal ab, und ob das Ganze ja vielleicht dann auch ins Titelrennen eingreift. Also es ist auch für die Premier League nicht so einfach, muss man auch zugeben. Also wir haben jetzt hier, glaube ich, ein paar valide Kritikpunkte gemacht. Ich möchte allerdings auch nicht derjenige bei der Premier League sein, der eben nach Jahrzehnten des Wegguckens jetzt anfangen muss, da Maßstäbe zu etablieren.
Das ist super schwierig. Und bei City muss man ganz kurz noch einen Satz, weil bei Everton, du hast es ja vorher gesagt, es waren Verluste, die die gemacht haben, die haben zu viel Geld ausgegeben und so weiter. Bei City ist es ja was anderes. Da war es jetzt nicht zu viel Geld, sondern es wurden Sponsorenverträge zu hoch angesetzt im Vergleich zum Marktstandard. Sie haben Spielerverträge zu hoch angesetzt, die aber nicht bekannt gegeben oder nicht ausgewiesen in ihren Bilanzen. Das sind auch ein paar Jugendspieler. Dann wurde, glaube ich, an Roberto Mancini eine Sonderzahlung geleistet, die nirgends aufgetreten ist. Solche Dinge waren es. Es ist jetzt nicht vergleichbar mit Everton. Das ist genau das, was ich meine. David Ornstein meint zum Beispiel auch, das finde ich sehr interessant, der Tatbestand trat irgendwie keine Ahnung, wie oft auf. Also Jack Wheelish, blablabla. Also mehrere Spieler. Und dann ist die Frage, wenn du ein Vergehen 70 mal machst, ob das dann schwerwiegender ist, als ob du 70 verschiedene machst. Das ist dann die Frage. Das können wir alle nicht einschätzen, wie die Premier League darauf reagiert. Ob die sagen, naja, die haben den Fehler 70 mal gemacht, ist egal. Jetzt haben wir es ihnen ja gesagt, beim 71. Mal wird es nicht passieren. Keine Ahnung, ob es dann doch passiert. Aber das ist dann die Frage, die dann die Premier League auch zu beantworten hat.
Also wir werden ganz sicher darüber noch sprechen. Wir werden aber auch sportlich noch über City sprechen. Und das hat unter anderem mit einem Mann zu tun, den wir schon häufig in der Ligatur besprochen haben oder erwähnt haben. Und in den letzten Wochen aber nicht, weil er verletzt war. Und das ist Kevin de Bruyne. Der ist zurück und nicht ganz so schlecht, dass er wieder zurück ist, oder?
Es war unfassbar. Ich hab das Spiel gemacht, Newcastle gegen Man City. Und es war wirklich, also Newcastle hat geführt zu dem Zeitpunkt. Kevin de Bruyne kommt rein mit neuer Frisur, sehr schick und macht einfach ein, ich kann es wirklich nur jedem ans Herz legen, das sich nochmal anzusehen. Das Highlight, weil er macht ein Tor, das wirklich eigentlich eher ein langer Ball ist. Er sieht genau, wenn ich jetzt dort den Ball so irgendwie reinschneide, was eher wirklich aussieht wie ein langer Ball in die Spitze, durch die Beine des Gegenspielers ins lange Eck, dann könnte der reingehen. Und er geht genau durch die Beine, er geht genau in die Ecke. Es ist wirklich perfekt getimt alles, es ist perfekt ausgeguckt. Unglaublich. Und dann am Schluss diese Flanke auf Oskar Bob, der den Ball natürlich auch perfekt mitnimmt, verwertet. Das ist sagenhaft. Aber dass er ihn auch sieht. Also City hat davor riesengroße Probleme gehabt. Also die ersten 70 Minuten waren Symptome der ganzen Saison. Dass sie ja, sie haben den Ball, ja, aber wenn dann Harlan auch noch fehlt und sie wirklich darauf angewiesen sind, irgendetwas zu kreieren, haben sie Probleme momentan, dann kommt die Beune und zeigt, Jungs, so geht es eigentlich. Und das war wirklich, glaube ich, das, ich habe es eben im Spiel gesagt, auch das ist ja schon eigentlich kitschig, das immer wieder zu sagen, aber es ist so, dieses Ende war so kitschig, keiner hätte gedacht, oder jeder hätte gedacht, wenn du ein Buch schreiben müsstest, schreib es so, der Beune kommt rein, macht ein Tor, macht eine Vorlage, alle jubeln. Und genauso kam es. Es musste einfach genauso sein. Es musste genauso sein.
Mit dem Siegtreffer eben in der 91. Minute. Und deswegen bleibt eben City an Liverpool dran. Arsenal und Tottenham, die haben schon fünf Punkte Rückstand auf die absolute Spitze. Ist es fair zu sagen, das Titelrennen wird zwischen den oberen drei entschieden, mit natürlich Aston Villa als krassen Außenseiter? Oder wie weit, würdest du sagen, geht denn der Bereich der Tabelle, aus dem der Titelträger kommen könnte?
Ich würde die schon noch mitnehmen, ehrlich gesagt. Also sie ist ja auch irgendwie – gestern habe ich wieder gelesen – Gary Neville sagt, Tottenham kann noch mit eingreifen und so. Also ich würde die allesamt nicht rausnehmen, weil wir eine Sache gelernt haben in dieser Saison. Immer wenn wir denken, eine Mannschaft hat es jetzt gerafft, jetzt sind die raus aus der Geschichte, dann verlieren die wieder. Also alle haben gesagt, Arsenal wird Meister. Die haben momentan die beste Phase. Jetzt brechen die komplett weg.
Zwei Niederlagen, ein Unentschieden in den letzten drei Spielen.
Dann dachten alle, City ist weg. Ich glaube, die waren fünf Spiele sieglos zwischendrin mal. Jetzt sind die wieder komplett da und alle sagen, es wird sowieso wieder City. Liverpool hat am Anfang keiner auch nur irgendetwas gesehen in denen. Jetzt plötzlich sind die ganz oben. Jetzt gibt es aber schon wieder die ersten, die sagen, gegen City können die nicht mithalten. Es ist momentan Tottenham. Die ersten zehn Spiele ungeschlagen. Dann plötzlich gab es eine Serie, weil ein paar Verletzte waren. Das ist wirklich das, was wir gelernt haben. In dieser Saison kann man es nicht sagen. Das macht mir am meisten Spaß, dass da oben nicht zwei weglaufen, nicht einer wegläuft, sondern dass alle Probleme haben und dass es spannend werden oder bleiben kann. Sagen wir mal, mindestens bis März.
Ja gut, wobei du hast mir doch mal erzählt, dass Manchester City im März und April nicht mehr verliert. Haben wir da nicht drüber geredet? Als City seine Schwächephase in der Hinrunde hatte, hast du gesagt, also hatten sie nicht. Und hast du gesagt, normalerweise haben sie jetzt immer die Schwächephase.
Man muss sich schön saufen. Ich hoffe wirklich, dass es spannend bleibt. Ich schlafe nicht in Vereinsbettwäsche, aber auch du weißt das am allerbesten. Aus der Heimat, das tut einfach gut, wenn mal ein anderer Meister werden würde. Das täte gut.
Ja, das ist allerdings wahr. Und die Geschichten sind halt auch dann einfach andere. Hast du das Gefühl, dass die Arbeit von Jürgen Klopp fair bewertet wird? Ich habe das Gefühl, dass man in der kritischen Phase von Liverpool viel mehr über Liverpool und eben sein Team gelesen hat, als jetzt in den letzten Wochen, wo es ja wirklich einfach zum Teil fantastisch war.
Ja, das ist halt auch ein deutsches Phänomen. Also ich habe dieses Interview mit Thomas Tuchel zum Beispiel auch gehört. Er sagt, die Deutschen sind halt einfach so. Also in Deutschland wird er immer anders wahrgenommen als auf der Insel. Aber man muss eine Sache auch sagen. Das ist jetzt auch wirklich nur eine Beobachtung. Jürgen Klopp ist halt auch ein, ich sag mal, lauter Charakter. Also im Sinne von er sagt halt auch Dinge, er eckt an mit seinen Sachen, er hält auch nicht hinterm Berg mit seinen Emotionen, sondern der sagt mal hier was, der sagt mal da was. Er ist manchmal jetzt auch nicht der allerbeste Verlierer, ehrlich gesagt, wenn irgendwas gegen ihn geht. Klar, sagt er ja eigentlich auch, dass er gar nicht so gut ist. Oder wenn man ein Spiel nicht so gut hat, oder wenn er irgendwas als ungerecht empfindet. Und das polarisiert auf der Insel halt auch mittlerweile. Also am Anfang fanden das alle superwitzig. Mittlerweile merke ich schon, dass auch der eine oder andere sich abnutzt an ihm. Und das ist, glaube ich, eher so der Punkt. Insgesamt, glaube ich, hat sich bei ihm jetzt wenig verändert. Vorausschreit natürlich immer schon diese, auch bei ihm so dieser Punkt. Manchmal sind mir die englischen Medien ein bisschen zu hart. Ein bisschen zu, teilweise auch wirklich zu boulevardesque. Und das, glaube ich, nervt ihn schon auch. Also das ist einfach so ein Abnutzungskampf, der immer voranschreitend ist.
Ja, also das, glaube ich, kann man definitiv sagen, wenn man sich beschäftigt mit eben Tränen in der Premier League. Es ist, glaube ich, noch mehr als in anderen Ligen ein krasser Abnutzungskampf. Weil einfach die Art der Berichterstattung eine andere ist, die Art der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung eine andere ist. Und du auch eben ganz andere Themen hast in der Premier League. Die Erwartungshaltung ist logischerweise eine andere. Und die Liga ist eine komplett andere als alle anderen Top-Ligen, über die wir so sprechen.
Die Journalisten, muss man auch sagen, sind natürlich auch weiter weg. Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich mal mit einem Journalisten telefoniert aus England, dann habe ich gesagt, wir haben die Nummer von Daniel Fahke. Dann hieß es, wie, ihr habt die Nummer von Daniel Fahke? Das geht ja gar nicht. Bei uns hat die keiner, also keiner darf mit dem sprechen. Das gibt es ja gar nicht. Und wir würden uns niemals trauen, mit dem zu sprechen. Na gut, wir telefonieren eigentlich mit den Trainern immer vor jedem Spiel. Das gibt es gar nicht. Dementsprechend sind die so weit weg. Es gibt kein öffentliches Training. Die müssen irgendwo auch Quellen, so Drittquellen vertrauen. Wenn die dann Quatsch erzählen, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt hundertprozentig stimmt, dann kann ich schon verstehen, dass ein Jürgen Klop sich auch mal hinsetzt und sagt, wo habt ihr denn den Mist jetzt wieder her? Auf der anderen Seite, er spricht halt auch nicht mit den Leuten. Weil es dann einfach in Englern so ist, das ist dann auch ein Teufelskreis. In Deutschland haben wir dann den großen Vorteil, für die Trainer mal einen Nachteil, dass wir ein paar Interne mehr wissen als der englische Journalist. Die sind da verhältnismäßig neidisch auf uns.
Ja, gut. Das kann ja auch ein Vorteil für die Trainer sein. Ich meine, wir zwei haben da schon so oft über Themen aus der Bundesliga geredet, wo du weißt, wenn ein Trainer dir etwas einordnet, vorher im Gespräch, bevor du in den Kommentar gehst, dann kannst du da ganz anders drüber sprechen. Und ich weiß verbrieft von vielen, vielen Beispielen, wo eben ein möglicherweise sehr kritisch anzunehmendes Thema gar nicht so kritisch dann live berichtet wurde, weil man ein paar Hintergründe dazu erfahren hat und dann eben gesehen hat, aha, so und so scheint das zu sein. Merke ich mir mal für den Hinterkopf. Und dann kommt irgendwann der sehr interessante Effekt. Das habe ich natürlich nicht, weil ich nicht mit den Trainern spreche, aber jemand wie du, du sprichst halt dann mit verschiedenen Trainern über den gleichen Spieler. Und wenn dann irgendwann sich quasi beim dritten Trainer Geschichten wiederholen oder eben Einschätzungen zu diesem Spieler, dann macht das ja auch deinen Job total wertvoll, weil dann kann man sich wirklich so halbwegs sicher sein, okay, gut, also dieser Spieler scheint außerhalb des Platzes ungefähr in diese Kategorie zu fallen. Also man kann es ja auch für sich nutzen. Ich verstehe, warum die Kultur da eine andere ist in der Premier League. Ist ja auch historisch gewachsen und so weiter, aber…
Genau, aber ich kann Jürgen Klopp da natürlich schon verstehen, wenn irgendwie berichtet wird, keine Ahnung, jetzt nehmen wir mal das Beispiel Kylian Mbappé, die sind sehr fortgeschritten, hieß es mal irgendwie. Und er sagt, wir haben mit dem gar nicht gesprochen, wo kommt denn der Mister? Dann kann ich schon verstehen, dass der vielleicht irgendwann mal sagt, das ist der 15. Fehlbericht von euch, was soll denn das? Kann ich dann schon verstehen. Und das wiederum nehmen die Medien dann auf, nehmen das persönlich, denken sich, was soll der Quatsch jetzt? Schreiben dann beim nächsten Mal wieder so und so, weil sie eben nicht mehr wissen, weil einfach die Kultur eine andere ist. Sie irgendwie aus der Ferne irgendwas einschätzen müssen, irgendwie zu sich zusammenklöppeln müssen. Und dann sieht es halt so aus. Also ich kann beide Seiten komplett verstehen. Macht es halt, glaube ich, in Englern auch nicht einfach. Wie gesagt, mit einem reden wir sehr, sehr häufig zu Chelsea. Der sagt immer, meine Quellen sagen. Also er selbst weiß es oftmals nicht, sondern er hat immer irgendjemand im Busch sitzen. Das ist aber das Einzige.
Und es wird natürlich aber halt auf Dauer auch nicht besser, wenn du dich dem komplett verschließst. Also Jürgen Klopp, er hat dann mal irgendwie ein über 2-stündiges Interview gegeben bei Matze Hischer im Hotel Matze. Aber er sagt dann selber im Interview, dass ich jetzt hier sitze, hat wesentlich damit zu tun, dass du dich null für Fußball interessierst und dich da auch überhaupt nicht auskennst. Auf der einen Seite total legitim, auf der anderen Seite denkt man sich aber auch, ja, man könnte sich aber auch jetzt, es gibt ja unterschiedliche Fußballmedien, da könnte man sich, wenn Jürgen Klopp bei euch sehr ist, bei Click & Rush, da würde er ein ganz anderes Interview führen. Vielleicht würde ihm auch die eine oder andere Frage nicht gefallen. Aber er könnte wahrscheinlich auch sehr, sehr viele Missverständnisse oder Ungenauigkeiten aus dem Weg räumen.
Ja, bestes Gegenbeispiel, wir hatten jetzt letztens bei Rondo Christian Eichner. Ich meine, das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Fallhöhe. Aber der setzt sich halt hin und antwortet auf alles. Also wir konnten den alles fragen und der weiß auch wie, also da brauchen wir uns ja auch nicht. Jürgen Klopp ist intelligent genug und auch gewandt genug, um selbst wenn ich ihm eine ASI-Frage stelle, in Anführungszeichen eine harte Frage, wo ich wirklich sage, was haben Sie denn taktisch da? Der weiß doch, wie er da rauskommt. Also das ist jetzt nicht das Ding. Aber ich will ihn jetzt auch nicht irgendwie in die Pfanne hauen, im Sinne von er muss mehr mit den Medien. Ich glaube, der macht schon genug. Ich habe das ja letztens auch mal mitgesehen. Ich musste mal nach dem Spiel ein Interview mit ihm führen, in der Mixed Zone. Ich musste schon eine Stunde warten, bis der kam. Aber nicht, weil der keinen Bock hatte oder so, sondern weil der halt schon mit 10.000 anderen Stationen reden musste. Also ich kann es schon verstehen, dass dem das irgendwann auch mal zum Hals raushängt. Die 15. Pressekonferenz, zum 15. Mal dieselbe Frage. Dann ist ein Journalist drei Wochen nicht da, in der vierten Woche kommt er dann wieder, stellt ihm dann wieder eine Frage, die er schon 13 Mal beantwortet hat. Dann teilweise mit einem falschen Kontext und so weiter und so fort. Also ich kann das schon auch verstehen. Ja, am Ende sind wir alle Profis oder sollten es sein, ist er auch. Aber dass irgendwann mal eine Antwort rauskommt, die jetzt nicht jeden streichelt, kann ich komplett nachvollziehen. Und da bin ich auch wirklich voll auf seiner Seite. Und ehrlich gesagt, es gibt auch teilweise Fragen. In der Vorbereitung schaue ich mir die Pressekonferenzen ja auch immer an. Es gibt manchmal Fragen, da denkst du dir als Journalist auch, sag mal, wie kann man so eine Frage stellen? Das weiß jeder da draußen, der ein Premier League Spiel gesehen hat, weiß es besser und würde diese Frage nicht stellen. Deswegen manchmal ist es schon auch irgendwie so. Und manchmal wollen die auch wirklich bei Schlagzeilen provozieren bei ihm. Das muss man auch ganz klar sagen.
Ja, und gleichzeitig, ach, ich würde das mal so gerne begleiten, einen Trainer und unter anderem eben bei diesem Interviewmarathon. Weil ich glaube, man macht sich da wirklich keine Vorstellung, gerade bei Topspielen, wie lange die noch unterwegs sind. Also für die Spieler ist es vorbei, für die Trainer beginnt dann nochmal anderthalb Stunden, zwei Stunden brutale Arbeit.
Und die müssen ja immer dieselbe Frage, weil jeder Journalist hat die gleiche, ist ja ganz normal, wie oft Pep Guardiola nach Kevin de Bruyne gefragt werden muss nach diesem Spiel. Das ist ganz normal, also das ist ja irre.
Und das ist ja immer etwas Positives. Das ist ja keine Fehlinterleitung des Schiedsrichters oder so.
Aber es ist vor dem Spiel genau dasselbe gewesen. Auch da haben wir manchmal Einblicke, wenn du siehst, die gehen von einem Mikrofon zum anderen und die gleiche Frage wird gestellt. Ja, warum? Ich weiß gar nicht, was es war bei Eddie Howe. Ah genau, Joel Linton fehlt. Und der gibt halt einfach, bei drei Stationen muss er die gleiche Antwort geben. Also es nimmt sich nicht aus dem Pool, sondern er sagt halt immer, that Joel Linton is missing, is very hard for us, blablabla. Und er sagt dann halt in fünf verschiedenen Wortlauten, er sagt das an fünf Stationen und danach denkst du dir auch, also es ist wirklich Wahnsinn. Deswegen kann ich schon verstehen, dass wenn der Jürgen Klopp zum 15. Mal gefragt wird, warum kommt Kiel an den Papet? Dummes Beispiel, aber weil es wahrscheinlich wirklich sehr polarisierend ist, dass der irgendwann mal beim sechsten Mal sagt, also jetzt kann ich es echt nicht mehr hören, wie sollen wir denn die 700 Millionen für den Kameraden auftreiben? Also ich kann es schon nachvollziehen. Und dann wird eben wieder eine Aussage von vor 13 Jahren um die Ohren gehauen, ja sie haben mal gesagt, sie haben kein Geld, jetzt haben sie aber Geld. Dann denkst du dir, ja, es hat sich halt ein paar Sachen ver… Ich kann es nachvollziehen, dass man dann irgendwann mal sagt, also jetzt kann ich es nicht mehr hören. Ich kann es, glaube ich, ich kann es mir vorstellen.
Genau und auf der anderen Seite, das nur zum Abschluss dieses Sondersegments gerade, ist aber ja auch die Aufgabe des Fragestellers oder der Fragestellerin, die offensichtlichen Fragen zu stellen. Du stehst nicht da, um dich zu verkünsteln, sondern du musst nach den drei großen Aufregern fragen. Und das ist auch undankbar. Und auch Journalistinnen und Journalisten müssen das lernen dürfen. Im Pressekonferenz, man darf auch mal eine dumme Frage stellen. Und ich hatte zum Beispiel mal Kontakt mit demjenigen, der mal Jürgen Klopp eine Frage gestellt hat und ihn gebeten hat, dass er keine Flosken in der Antwort verwendet. Da hat Jürgen Klopp ihn komplett eingesagt. Und das war – Hat dich auch schon? Etwas frech formuliert. Aber das kann so eine Journalistenkarriere auch ganz schnell ein Stoppschild dran machen. Da war nämlich dann mit, du gehst jetzt nicht mehr zur Pressekonferenz. Und wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere, ist er auch nämlich seitdem nicht mehr im Sport unterwegs gewesen, sondern musste sich ein anderes Feld suchen. Weil einfach eine etwas zu forsch- oder unglücklich formulierte Frage, er hatte es nicht ganz so gemeint, wie es ankam. Und dann eben die entsprechende Reaktion von Klopp dafür gesorgt hat, dass die komplette Redaktion gesagt hat, okay, du bist im Grunde raus. Also es ist auch auf der anderen Seite des Balles oder des Mikrophones nicht so.
Ich hatte das mal mit Arsene Wenger. Ich weiß noch, es war meine erste Pressekonferenz und ich wollte da unbedingt mit. Wenn Arsene Wenger in Dortmund ist, da wollte ich unbedingt mit. Für Skysport News war ich damals im Volo-Austausch, weiß ich noch. Und ich trottel, Stelldeben hat einfach, da war Serge Nabry damals so zwei, drei Spiele mal gemacht in der Premier League, musste aushelfen, mehr oder minder. Und dann war halt die Option, er könnte in der Champions League vielleicht auch spielen gegen Dortmund. Ich wollte ihm die Frage stellen, ist das eine Möglichkeit? Und ich trottel, Stelldeben, super klug wie ich bin, einfach eine geschlossene Frage. Ist es eine Möglichkeit, dass Serge Nabry im Kader ist? Und Arsene Wenger schaut mich an und sagt, ja. Und alle lachen natürlich in dem Raum und ich denke mir, du voll trottel, ey. Du hast Journalistik studiert, du hast und so weiter. Und 10.000 Interviews und du hast alles in der Theorie. Und dann stellst du dem eine geschlossene Frage, du Holzkopf. Und der war dann aber so cool, als er gesagt hat, der hat das kurz abgewartet, hat sich diesen Lacher geholt und hat dann aber geantwortet, yes, Serge Nabry is a great player, blablabla. Und das war dann so, Gott sei Dank, wir haben die Antwort bekommen. Und ich stehe jetzt nicht ganz. Aber in dem Moment, dann Stefan Schäuble war damals der Kollege, der sagte, na hast du es gemerkt, es ist doch nicht so einfach. Wenn du sitzt da, denkst du, in einem normalen Gespräch würde der antworten. Auf einer Pressekonferenz ist eine andere Fallhöhe. Nochmal, weil da sitzen halt 15 andere, die es besser wissen. Und du vielleicht auch so, in dieser Stresssituation ist es jetzt auch nicht. Aber ich war damals, das war wahrscheinlich meine erste Pressekonferenz überhaupt. Und du denkst halt dann auch nicht so weit, ja wie könnte der jetzt antworten? Was du ja normalerweise im Interview, wenn du vorbereitest, das machst. Was wird der wohl antworten? Wie könnte ich ihm entgegnen? Machst du auf der Pressekonferenz nicht. Ich war ja damals einfach nur froh, den Finger, ich war damals, weil ich mir in die Hose gemacht habe, den Finger überhaupt zu heben.
Ja, genau, das kommt ja dazu.
Und dann kann das halt passieren, ja. Keine Ausrede für einen Journalisten, der das seit 13 Jahren macht, der weiß es besser. Ist schon klar, aber ich hätte es damals auch besser wissen können.
Ja gut, aber so ist das. Und dann muss Malia auch reagieren auf das, was passiert. Ich war bei der letzten Pressekonferenz Thomas Tuchel nach dem Spiel gegen Hoffenheim. Das war das erste Spiel, wo ich akkreditiert war. Das heißt, Tuchel kennt mich gar nicht, er kennt mich jetzt auch danach nicht. Aber, und ich wollte eine Frage zur Besetzung der Doppel-Sechs sprechen und zu den unterschiedlichen Aufgabenverteilungen. Und vor mir stellt Florian Plettenberg, of all people, eine Frage zur Doppel-Sechs, natürlich mit der Anschlussfrage muss jetzt Palinja kommen. Also natürlich komplett anderer Einfallswinkel. Und da habe ich dann aber während der Antwort auch kurz überlegt, ok, muss ich mir jetzt ganz spontan noch eine komplett andere Frage überlegen, die ja auch nicht total bescheuert sein sollte, oder traue ich mich jetzt einfach zu sagen, ja, also ich möchte jetzt nochmal aus einem taktischen Grund über die Doppel-Sechs sprechen, bin einfach bei der Frage geblieben, viel zu kompliziert gestellt. Antwort war quasi völlig belanglos, aber ja, so was passiert dann eben auch. Wir haben uns ein bisschen verquatscht, Yogi, und das, obwohl wir ja noch gar nicht fertig sind. Wir müssen ja noch MVP, Unsung Hero und Moment des Spieltags oder der letzten Wochen besprechen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob du da schon was mitgebracht hast, ansonsten kannst du es dir bestimmt auch jetzt noch spontan überlegen. Hättest du einen MVP für mich?
Ehrlich gesagt Kevin de Bruyne, ich glaube, ich musst du da nehmen. Der wertvollste Spieler im Sinne von Basketball ist ja immer, wer macht bei einem Team den größten Unterschied. Das war an diesem Wochenende Kevin de Bruyne. Jürgen Klopp hat ja gesagt, Kevin de Bruyne macht sich warm und das ganze Land fängt an zu zittern. Er hatte recht, es war genauso. Und vor allem, der war schon mal mehr in Form. Du merkst, dass der noch leicht eingerostet ist. Und das macht das Ganze noch viel dramatischer, ehrlich gesagt.
Ok, da können wir uns ja auf was freuen. Gibt es einen Unsung Hero für dich? Ich habe zum Beispiel neulich gelesen, aber du kannst natürlich auch was komplett anderes nehmen. Aber wie Bournemouth seine Saison so ein bisschen gedreht hat, ist ja durchaus bemerkenswert. Also aktuell jetzt Tabellen Mittelfeld, 25 Punkte haben aus den letzten sechs Spielen vier Siege und einen Unentschieden geholt.
Ja, da würde ich genau auch einen Spieler nehmen, Dominic Solenki. Er ist momentan einer der besten Stürmer der Liga. Ich muss nachschauen, wie viele Saisontore er hat. Aber der ist momentan – bei dem hieß es ja, er ist bei zwölf Saisontoren. Da hieß es ja im Endeffekt, der ist total durch Fehleinkauf von Liverpool damals verpflichtet, die ersten 30 Spiele, glaube ich, habe ich mal aufgeschrieben, hat er gar nicht getroffen oder so. Dann die zweite Liga mit runter, da auch jetzt nicht signifikant gewesen am Anfang. Und jetzt plötzlich ist er momentan einer der besten Stürmer der Liga, muss man ganz klar sagen, in den letzten Wochen vor allem gerade gekommen. Richtig gut Lauf. Dementsprechend würde ich sagen, das ist momentan einer, der wahrscheinlich, ja, muss Anzang Hero sein, weil im Endeffekt, glaube ich, hat den nicht mal überhaupt jemand auf der Karte. Viele werden sagen, wer ist das? Also der jetzt nicht unbedingt jede Woche Premier League schaut, muss ihn auch nicht kennen, weil Bournemouth jetzt auch nicht das glänzendste Team ist, insgesamt von der Größe des Klubs. Dementsprechend würde ich den auf jeden Fall nehmen. Also den sich mal anschauen, ist momentan wirklich auf jeden Fall lohnenswert.
Und damit haben wir Bournemouth auch noch kurz abgehandelt. Das freut mich auch. Und was war der Moment der letzten Wochen oder auch des letzten Spieltags für dich?
Ja, auch das, glaube ich, war wirklich Kevin de Bruyne. Also es ist zwar doof, das jetzt wieder zu verwenden, aber es ist, glaube ich, der Moment gewesen, auch wenn ich nochmal nachgeschaut letztens so, was so die Aufrufzahlen waren und so. Also das ist schon um die Welt gegangen, dass der zurück ist. Und die Art und Weise, wie es passiert ist. Aber wenn ich wirklich den Moment runterbrechen müsste, dann wäre es wahrscheinlich echt diese Vorlage am Schluss nochmal. Und wie City da zurückgekommen ist, auch mit der… Also Oskar Bob, den muss man auch erstmal so machen. Das, glaube ich, war wirklich der Moment, muss man sagen, glaube ich, des letzten Spieltags. Der ja auch, muss man auch sagen, der ist jetzt zerpflückt. So viele Spiele waren jetzt nicht. Dementsprechend ist es jetzt auch eine kleine Grundgesamtheit, aber das war schon der Moment.
Jogi, vielen, vielen Dank. Das hat, wie immer, große Freude gemacht. Danke, dass du mit dabei warst.
Sehr, sehr gerne. Ich danke.
Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für die Aufmerksamkeit. Ihr könnt mal gucken, auf Rasenfunk.de ist es jetzt wieder losgegangen. Wir haben Schwerpunkt zum 1. FC Köln gemacht. Wir haben natürlich den letzten Bundesligaspieltag aufbereitet. Und es gibt ein Tribüngespräch zur Entwicklung des Rasenfunks. Und da erzählen wir unter anderem, warum wir den Kiosk einstellen. Im Kiosk gibt es jetzt 30% Rabatt auf alles. Wir müssen unser Lager leer räumen. Warum wir das machen, erfahrt ihr im Tribüngespräch. Und einkaufen könnt ihr aber unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de. So ist die URL. Man sollte sich nicht nebenher noch Notizen für die Show Notes machen. Denn ich pack den Link in die Show Notes. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt gesund, bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.